- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools for everyday life.
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor of
neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today my guest is Dr. Nolan Williams.
Dr. Williams is a medical doctor
and professor of psychiatry
and behavioral sciences
at Stanford University School of Medicine.
His laboratory and clinic
focus on depression
and other mood disorders.
They focus specifically on the use
of transcranial magnetic stimulation,
which is a brain stimulation technique
that can either activate or
quiet specific brain circuits,
as well as circuits within the body,
in order to treat depression
and other mood disorders.
Other laboratories and clinics use TMS.
What sets apart the work of
Nolan Williams and colleagues is
that they combine TMS
with other treatments,
and some of those treatments
are among the more cutting edge
that you've probably
heard about these days,
including ibogaine, psilocybin,
MDMA, cannabis, DMT,
and other drugs that at this
point in time are experimental
in terms of clinical trials,
but that at least the
preliminary data show
hold great promise for the
treatment of depression
and other mood disorders.
In the course of my
discussion with Dr. Williams,
we covered things such as the history
of each of these drugs,
how they came to be,
and their current status in
terms of their clinical use
and legality.
We also talk about their safety profiles
both in children and in adults,
and we talk about what the
future of psychedelic research
and clinical use really looks like.
For instance, we discuss
how a number of laboratories
and clinics are modifying psychedelics
to remove some of their
hallucinogenic properties
while maintaining some
of their antidepressant
or anti trauma properties.
You'll also learn about
some fascinating research
in Dr. Williams' laboratory
focused on ketamine,
which is a drug that is
increasingly being used
to treat depression.
And contrary to common belief,
the effects of ketamine in
terms of relieving depression
may not actually arise from
its dissociative effects.
One thing that you'll find extraordinary
about Dr. Williams is
that not only does he have
vast knowledge of the various
treatments for depression,
but that he and his laboratory
are really combining
these treatments in the most potent way.
That is, combining psychedelic treatments
with brain-machine interface,
or combining brain-machine interface
with particular learning protocols.
That is, neuroplasticity protocols,
which can directly change
the brain in specific ways.
So today you're going to
learn a tremendous amount
about the neural circuitry
underlying depression,
as well as positive moods.
You'll also learn about
all the various drugs
that I described,
and you're really going to
learn about the current status
and future of the treatment
of mood disorders.
Today, you'll also learn about
a number of ongoing studies
in Dr. Williams' laboratory.
I should mention that they
are recruiting subjects
for these studies.
If you go to BSL,
which stands for Brain
Stimulation Laboratory,
so that's bsl.stanford.edu,
you have the opportunity to apply
for one of these clinical trials
for the treatment of depression
and other mood disorders.
I confess that the conversation
with Dr. Williams was,
for me, one of the more stimulating
and informative
conversations I've ever had
about psychedelics,
which is simply to say that his breadth
and depth of knowledge on
that topic is incredible,
and his breadth and depth of knowledge
in terms of the underlying brain science
and how it can all be combined
with clinical applications
is also extraordinary.
I'm sure that by the
end of today's episode,
you're going to come away
with a tremendous amount of
knowledge about the clinical
and non-clinical uses of those substances,
and you're going to understand a lot more
about how the healthy
and diseased brain work.
I'm pleased to announce
that the Huberman Lab
Podcast has now launched
a premium channel.
I want to be very clear
that the Huberman Lab
Podcast will continue
to be released every Monday
at zero cost to consumer
and there will be no change in
the format of these podcasts.
The premium channel is a response
to the many questions we
get about specific topics,
and it will allow me to really drill deep
into specific answers
related to those topics.
So once a month,
I'm going to host an ask
me anything, so called AMA,
where you can ask me anything
about specific topics covered
on the Huberman Lab Podcast,
and I will answer those questions.
Those of course will be recorded.
There will also be other
premium content available
to premium subscribers,
such as transcripts and
short videos of new tools
and unique tools for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
If you want to check
out the premium channel,
you can go to hubermanlab.com/premium.
There is a $10 a month
charge or $100 per year,
and I should mention that a
large portion of the proceeds
from the Huberman Lab
premium channel will go
to support scientific research
that develops the very sorts of tools
that we talk about on
the Huberman Lab Podcast.
The rest of the support
for the Huberman Lab Podcast
premium channel will go
to supporting the regular
Huberman Lab Podcast.
Again, that's hubermanlab.com/premium.
Before we begin,
I'd like to emphasize that
this podcast is separate
from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and DNA
to help you better understand your body
and help you reach your health goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done
for the simple reason
that many of the factors
that impact your immediate
and long-term health
can only be analyzed with
a quality blood test.
One problem with a lot of DNA tests
and blood tests, however,
is you get data back about
levels of metabolic factors,
levels of hormones, et cetera,
but you don't know what to
do with that information.
InsideTracker makes interpreting your data
and knowing what to do
about it exceedingly easy.
They have a personalized
platform where you can go
and you can see those levels
of hormones, metabolic factors,
lipids, et cetera,
and they point to specific
nutritional tools,
behavioral tools, supplement
based tools, et cetera,
that can help you bring those numbers
into the ranges that are optimal for you.
If you'd like to try InsideTracker,
you can go to InsideTracker.com/Huberman
to get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans.
Again, that's InsideTracker.com/Huberman
to get 20% off.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress covers
with cooling, heating, and
sleep tracking capacity.
I started sleeping on an
Eight Sleep mattress cover
a few months ago, and
it is simply incredible.
In fact, I don't even
like traveling anymore
because they don't have
Eight Sleep mattress covers
in hotels and Airbnbs.
One of the reasons
I love my Eight Sleep mattress
cover so much is that,
as you may have heard before
on this podcast or elsewhere,
in order to fall and stay deeply asleep,
you need your body temperature to drop
by about one to three degrees.
And I tend to run warm at night,
which makes it hard to sleep
and sometimes wakes me up
in the middle of the night.
When you sleep on an Eight
Sleep mattress cover,
you can program the temperature
of that mattress cover
for specific times in the early, middle,
and late part of your night so
that the mattress stays cool.
And as a consequence, you
sleep very, very deeply.
It also tracks your sleep,
so it's paying attention to
how many times you're moving,
how deep your sleep is.
It gives you a sleep score,
all wonderful data to help
you enhance your sleep.
And of course, sleep is the
foundation of mental health,
physical health, and performance,
which makes an Eight Sleep a terrific tool
for enhancing not just your sleep,
but all aspects of your life really.
If you're interested in trying
a Eight Sleep mattress cover,
you can go to EightSleep.com/Huberman
to check out the Pod 3 cover,
and you can save $150 at checkout.
Eight Sleep currently ships
to the USA, to Canada, the UK,
and select countries in
the EU and Australia.
Again, that's EightSleep.com/Huberman
to save $150 at checkout.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by ROKA.
ROKA makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are the absolute highest quality.
The company was founded by
two all American swimmers
from Stanford, and everything
about ROKA eyeglasses
and sunglasses were designed
with performance in mind.
I've spent a lifetime
working on the visual system,
and I can tell you that your
visual system has to contend
with some pretty significant challenges
in order to be able to see clearly
as you move from one area to the next.
For instance,
when you go from a shady
area to a bright area.
ROKA understands this and
have designed their sunglasses
and eyeglasses accordingly
so you always see with crystal clarity.
In addition,
because they were initially
designed for performance,
things like running and biking,
they're extremely lightweight,
but they have a terrific aesthetic.
So unlike a lot of
eyeglasses and sunglasses
that were designed for sports
and make you look like a cyborg,
they have styles that make
you look like a cyborg
if you like those, but
they also have styles
that you'd be perfectly
comfortable wearing to work
or out to dinner, et cetera.
They're really terrific glasses.
I love mine because I
can wear them anywhere
and I also use them when
running and going out hiking,
et cetera.
If you'd like to try ROKA
eyeglasses or sunglasses,
you can go to ROKA, that's ROKA.com,
and enter the code Huberman
to save 20% off your first order.
Again, that's ROKA, ROKA.com,
and enter the code Huberman at checkout.
On many episodes of the
Huberman Lab Podcast,
we talk about supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them.
Things like enhancing sleep
and the depth of sleep,
or for enhancing focus
and cognitive ability,
or for enhancing energy or
adjusting hormone levels
to optimal range for you.
The Huberman Lab Podcast is now partnered
with Momentous supplements.
To find the supplements we discussed
on the Huberman Lab Podcast,
you can go to livemomentous,
spelled O-U-S,
livemomentous.com/huberman.
And I should just mention that the library
of those supplements is
constantly expanding.
Again, that's livemomentous.com/huberman.
And now for my discussion
with Dr. Nolan Williams.
Thanks for joining today.
I'm really excited to
have this conversation.
It's been a long time coming
and I have a lot of questions
about different compounds,
psychedelics in particular.
- Yeah.
- But before we get into that discussion,
I want to ask you about
depression, broadly speaking.
Intractable depression.
How common depression is or isn't.
I heard you say in a
wonderful talk that you gave,
that depression is
perhaps the most debilitating
condition worldwide.
And yet,
in contrast to other medical
conditions like cancer,
we actually have a fairly
limited number of tools
to approach depression.
And yet number of tools
and the potency of those tools is growing.
So if you could educate us on depression,
I would really appreciate it.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So depression is a condition that,
it has a lot of manifestations, you know.
So you can have kind of a depression
that's primarily loss of interest.
You can have folks who feel very anxious
and they're kind of overactive.
You can have people who don't
have any anxiety at all,
and they're very underactive
and they have low
motivation to do anything.
You know, so you have this
huge range of symptoms
that are in that umbrella of depression.
And some of our work is to actually work
with folks like Conor Liston and Cornell,
and try to actually get biotypes
based off of neuroimaging
to see if we can kind of parse
out the different depression
kind of presentations,
and see that clinically,
and also see that in the brain.
Depression is the most
disabling condition worldwide.
What's interesting about depression is
it's both a risk factor
for other illnesses,
and it makes other medical and
psychiatric illnesses worse,
right?
So recently the American Heart
Association added depression
as the fourth major risk factor
for coronary artery disease, right?
So alongside the risk
factors that we know,
hypertension, high blood
pressure, hyperlipidemia,
high cholesterol, and diabetes,
you know, high blood sugar,
those three have been on
the list for a long time
and depression ended up
being added to the list
as the fourth one.
And you know, really interesting, right?
So in addition to taking medications
to address those other three risk factors,
we really have to be thinking
about how do you treat
folks with depression
to reduce the risk of having
a heart attack in the future?
And, you know, there's some
of that's being worked on now,
but we don't have a complete solution
to thinking about that at this time.
And then the other thing
that's interesting is
once you have a heart attack,
in the individuals that end
up having a heart attack,
the risk of having depression
after the heart attack is
higher than the normal population, right?
And so a lot of what we're
doing in the lab actually is
measuring kind of brain heart connections.
And we can actually, with
transcranial magnetic stimulation,
a form of brain stimulation,
we can actually decelerate the heart rate
and capture that heart rate deceleration
over the mood regulatory regions.
And so actually a direct
probe of that connection.
So it's interesting.
And so, you know, as you
said a second ago, you know,
it's a very disabling condition.
Moderate depression's about as disabling
as having a heart attack,
acutely having a heart attack.
Severe depression is disabling,
is having cancer without
treatment, you know,
and dying from a cancer without treatment.
And so, you know, it's
kind of underappreciated
just how disabling
depression is in that way.
And I think important
as stigma is consistently
kind of being reduced
over the years for mental illnesses,
then the idea that we can start
really putting more funding
and putting more focus at
the federal level, you know,
private foundation level, whatever it is,
at a given university
to thinking about developing treatments.
We've been very interested
in a very particular
clinical set of problems
around the most severe and
the most high acuity settings
that folks with depression
end up being in.
And that's in, you
know, emergency settings
where they go into inpatient units.
And you know, in the rest of medicine,
if it's talking about heart attacks,
if I start having chest pain right now
and you bring me to a
primary care doctor's office,
they're going to have a
certain number of tests
and treatments, right?
But very limited cuz it's
an outpatient facility.
If you bring me to the
emergency room after that,
there are more tests and more treatments.
If you put me in the
ICU or in the cath lab
where they do invasive
procedures to the heart,
there are more tests and more treatments.
In psychiatry, as we elevate
the acuity of an individual,
you go from being just
depressed to being depressed
and now thinking about ending your life,
the number of treatments
actually go down on average.
I mean, in some scenarios, they go up,
but on average they go down
and there are no tests, right?
And so we've been very focused
on that particular problem.
Somebody that maybe was doing, you know,
fairly okay with a pretty
moderate depression
and then their depression gets worse
and then they end up in
an emergency setting.
And the field really
hasn't developed a way
of consistently being
able to treat that problem
and folks end up getting
the same standard oral antidepressants
that they've been getting outpatient.
And I came to this because
I, you know, dual trained
as a neurologist and psychiatrist,
went back and forth between
neurology and psychiatry,
saw that in neurology we
have all of these ways
of treating acute brain based problems
and really wanted to
emulate that in psychiatry
and find ways to develop
and engineer new, you know,
brain based solutions.
- There's a lot to unpack there.
One thing that you said is,
I'd like to focus on a bit
more because I think we hear
that the brain and the
heart are connected,
but you described, I believe,
a direct relationship
between areas of the brain
associated with emotion
and heart rate.
- [Nolan] Yes.
- And that makes perfect
logical sense to me.
But I think at the same time,
many people out there probably
think of the relationship
between the heart and
the mind as kind of woo
or kind of a soft biology.
But here you're talking about
an actual physical connection.
- [Nolan] Yep.
- Between, what area of the brain is it?
- The first place where the
stimulation goes is called
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex.
It's kind of the sense of control,
kind of governor of the brain.
And then what we know is
that when you use a magnet,
use kind of what we call Faraday's Law,
this idea of using a magnetic pulse
to induce an electrical current
and electrically conducting substances.
So in this case, brain tissue,
but not skull or scalp
or any of that, or hair.
You avoid all that, just the brain tissue.
Then you have a direct
depolarization of cortical neurons,
you know, the surface
of the brain's neurons,
in this dorsolateral prefrontal.
And if you do that in the
actual scanner, which we can do,
you can see that that distributes down
into the anterior cingulate and
the insula and the amygdala.
And ultimately the tract
goes into something called
the nucleus tractus solitarius
and ultimately into the
vagus nerve into the heart.
So the heart very consistently
seems to be the end organ
of the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex.
If you measure heart rate in standard ways
that cardiologists measure heart rate
and you stimulate over
this left dorsolateral,
you get a deceleration of the heart rate
and it's very time locked
to the stimulation.
So it's a two second train of stimulation.
At one second, you see the deceleration,
it goes down about 10 beats per minute,
and then it'll drift back
up and there's a break
for eight seconds on the stimulation.
Drifts back up and the
stimulation goes back in
and then the heart rate goes back down.
And so you see the
heart rate just do this,
10 beats per minute every train.
And so we know, and if you
do that over visual cortex,
you don't get that,
or motor cortex, you don't
get any of those findings.
It's really specific to
this kind of control region
of the brain.
And so, yeah, it seems to, you know,
it's our work, other folks' work.
Martin Arens in Europe, the Netherlands,
work showing the same connections.
I think it's been replicated
like four or five times.
- So you mentioned left
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex.
Anytime I hear about
lateralization of function,
I get particularly curious
because obviously we have
two mirror symmetric sides
of the brain.
There are, you know,
rare exceptions to this,
like the pineal and things of that sort
that there is only one pineal.
What is special
about the left dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex?
Does this have anything
to do with handedness,
right hand or left hand?
Because we know right-hand
and left-handedness has a lot
to do with lateralization
of function for language,
a topic for another time.
But why do you think
that left dorsolateral prefrontal
cortex would be connected
to the heart in this way?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I think, so left
dorsolateral is thought
to be the side that when you excite it,
when you kind of do
excitatory stimulation,
potentiating sort of stimulation,
that you can reduce depressive symptoms.
And a guy by the name of Mike
Fox at Harvard demonstrated
that if you have strokes in
the brain that cause depression
and you put them on the human connectome,
a hundred, you know, thousand patient map,
and you ask the question
what they're all
functionally connected to?
Left dorsolateral.
If you take lesions that
cause mania in individuals
and you put those all on
the human connectome map
and ask what the one common
area they're all connected to,
it's the right dorsolateral.
And so there seems to be
a hemispheric, you know,
balancing of mood between
these two brain regions.
And we know this from an
experimental standpoint too,
because you can take
individuals with depression
and you can excite the left
or you can inhibit the right
and they're both antidepressant.
You can excite the right
and that's anti-manic in some studies.
And so this idea that there
is this hemispheric balancing
of mood is quite interesting, right?
- It's incredibly interesting.
And just so people know,
if you're curious what the connectome is,
connectome is a term that
was built out of this notion
of genomes being large collections
of sequencing and mapping of genes.
They're proteomes of proteins,
of connectomes is so-called connectomics,
of connections between neurons.
So the Human Connectome Project is ongoing
and I find that incredible
that within the Connectome Project,
they can identify these regularities
of right versus left
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex.
Especially since I've looked
at a fair number of brains
from humans, certainly
not as many as you have.
And if you look at the
architecture, the layers,
the cell types, and
even the neurochemicals
of which cells are expressing,
say, dopamine or serotonin
or receiving input from areas
that make dopamine or serotonin,
they don't look that different
on the right and left side.
And yet here we're talking
about a kind of an accelerator
and a brake, if you will,
on depression and mania
using what, at least by my eye
and I think other people's
eye look to be basically
the same set of of bits.
The same parts list, more or less.
So what gives these properties
to the right and left
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex?
Is it the inputs they receive?
Is this something that we
learn during development
or do you think that
we come into the world
with these hemispheric biases?
- Yeah, it's a great question.
And you know, it hasn't been worked out,
which your original question was around,
in a left handed individual,
which as you know,
25% of those folks end up
having a right brain dominance
or 1% of right-handed people
have a right brain dominance
if it's flipped, right?
And unfortunately that
study still hasn't been done
at the level, 'cause that would
be probably pretty helpful
for teasing some of this out.
But, you know, it's still
being sorted out, right?
We know enough to know
this phenomenon exists
because we can use TMS as a probe
and do these sorts of manipulations.
But to my knowledge,
there hasn't been anybody that's
gotten so interested in it
that they've been able to get
a mechanism of why that is.
But, you know, it's
kind of empirically true
in the sense that you can push
and pull on those systems,
or in the case of strokes that folks have,
and then you kind of get their
brains and their brain images
and look at where the strokes landed,
those kind of causal
bits of information point
to this asymmetry.
- Interesting.
Well, in that case, going
with what we do know,
that stimulation of
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
slows the heart rate down,
transiently, but it slows it down,
and seems to alleviate at least
some symptoms of depression,
leads me to the question of
why would that be the case?
Does it tell us anything
fundamental about depression
that anxiety is inherent to depression?
I think a faster heart rate is, you know,
part and parcel with anxiety.
In my laboratory, we've studied fear a bit
in animals and in humans,
and we often observe bradycardia
where somebody or an animal
is afraid of something
and rather than the
heart rate speeding up,
it actually slows down,
something that most people
don't think about or recognize.
But given that stimulation
of dorsolateral prefrontal
cortex slows the heart rate down
and can alleviate depressive symptoms
and that there are other
ways to slow the heart down,
I have two questions.
What do you think this tells us
about the basic architecture of depression
and its physiology at
the level of the heart?
And does the circuit run in
the opposite direction too?
If one were to have or find other ways
to slow the heart rate down,
say with a beta blocker,
does that help alleviate depression?
- Yeah, no, that's a great question.
So I'll answer the second question first.
So we know that in the
ongoing trials of this,
if you stimulate in the vagus nerve,
in an implanted vagus nerve stimulator,
you can actually, you know, have this,
the afferent parts of the
vagus project ultimately up
to the DLPFC through the cingulate
through these anterior
insula, so that same,
that obviously the same tract, right?
And you can stimulate there
and alleviate depression,
which seems very unusual, right?
You're stimulating a cranial
nerve down on the neck.
But if you can get up into the brain,
you actually can improve
depressive symptoms.
And so, you know, more evidence
that this is a kind of a
whole track and system.
And if you stimulate
in part of that system,
it appears that you can improve mood.
- And what if I were somebody
who did not have a stimulating
electrode in my vagus nerve
and I was dealing with minor depression
and I decided I wanted to
take some other approach
to slow my heart rate down by the vagus?
For instance, exhale emphasized breathing
or deliberately slow cadence
breathing, things of that sort.
Is there any evidence that
behavioral interventions
of those kinds can alleviate depression
or some symptoms of depression?
And is there any evidence
that it does indeed feed back
to the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
to achieve some of that alleviation?
- Absolutely, yeah.
So there's a number of studies
implicating the dorsolateral
in, say, you know, meditation,
mindfulness, that sort of thing.
And they're small studies,
but pretty well designed
studies suggesting
that behavioral interventions
in mild depression
actually work quite well.
There seems to be a volitional
threshold for depression
where at some point you start losing,
you go from being
completely in total volition
to having kind of semi-volition.
You have thoughts
that you really have a
hard time controlling
and that sort of thing.
And when you go through that threshold,
at some point it gets harder and harder
for those sorts of things
to kind of kick in and work.
And the extreme form of
that is catatonia, right?
Where people in a very
severe form of depression get
kind of stuck motorically, right?
And they obviously can't,
they have no control
or very limited control.
And so, you know, I
think there's a threshold
in which these sorts of
interventions will work.
Exercise seems to really
be a good treatment
for mild depression and it may work
through the mechanism
you're describing, right?
As we all know, you know,
athletes hold a lower resting heart rate
than folks that aren't, you
know, if you were an athlete,
you had a lower resting heart
rate, you stopped exercising,
and a couple years later
your resting heart rate
in many cases goes up, right?
And so maybe that's part of the process.
I'm not aware of any
studies specifically looking
at dorsolateral prefrontal physiology
pre-post exercise, but it
would be a great study.
I think that would be really
helpful to understanding this,
especially if you had a
correlation of changes
in kind of lowering of, say,
heart rate with mood improvements.
There's been a lot of work
with heart rate variability
and depression and, you know,
studies kind of point towards it.
Not every study is positive for this,
but quite a few studies say basically
that lower heart rate
variability is associated
with, you know, moderate
to severe depression.
And that may be part of that mechanism
of that heart brain risk.
- So I'm both intrigued
and a little bit perplexed
by this relationship between
heart rate and depression.
On the face of it, I would think
of depression as depressed.
So lower heart rate might
make somebody more depressed.
You even mentioned catatonia
or somebody that just
doesn't seem motivated
or excited to do anything.
I think of mania as elevated
heart rate and being excited.
On the other hand, I realize that anxiety,
which you know, brings about ideas
as elevated heart rate is
also built into depression.
Which brings me back to
what you said earlier,
which is that when we say depression,
are we really talking about
four or five different?
- Yeah, that's right.
- Disorders, for lack of a better word.
And for what percentage of
people that have depression
does some approach to
reducing heart rate work?
Whether or not it's stimulation
of the left dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
by way of transcranial
magnetic stimulation
or by taking a beta blocker
or by stimulating the vagus.
Can we throw out a number, a rough number?
Does that help, 30%, 50%?
How long lasting is that relief?
- Yeah, and to be clear,
the deceleration of the heart rate is
in the moment when the
stimulation is happening,
but it's not something
that's necessarily maintained chronically.
It's more of an indicator that
you're in the right network
more than it appears
to be itself, you know,
central to the mechanism.
The heart rate variability piece may be,
and there's some studies
that link the two,
but the actual deceleration
seems to be much more
of a marker that you're
in the right system.
But you know, it very well could be
that the heart rate system
and the mood system just
sit next to each other
and the stimulation hits both.
If you look at how much of
the variance in the mood is
explained by the heart rate deceleration,
it's not a huge amount, right?
So it only explains a small percentage.
And so it's unlikely that
simply reducing the heart rate.
And in fact, you know, for many years,
propranolol and these sorts of drugs
actually were implicating
causing depression.
And so that's been kind of
debunked, but it's unlikely
that simply decelerating
the heart rate's going to
improve depression.
But what it does tell you is
that if you're in that area
that is the mood regulatory area,
there's some parasympathetic
cortical kind of process
that's going on that gets in
and causes this to happen.
And it's, you know, it's
independent of mood.
You can take a normal healthy
individual and you can do this
and they're going to
decelerate their heart rate.
- I'm so glad you mentioned
the parasympathetic nervous system,
which of course is the,
most people think of
as the rest and digest
or the kind of calming side of
the autonomic nervous system.
As I'm hearing you say all of this,
and in particular what you just told me,
which is that it's not
as if having a lower
heart rate protects you
against depression
or a higher heart rate is
associated with depression,
although at the extremes
that might be true,
but rather it's something
about the regulatory network,
the ability to control
your own nervous system
to some extent.
And when I think about the
autonomic nervous system,
I like to think about it as a seesaw
of, you know, alertness and calmness,
and when you're asleep
it's a lot of calmness,
and when you're panicking it's
a lot of alertness to the...
But that, and I don't think
this has ever been defined,
and when I teach the medical students
at Stanford neuroanatomy, my wish is
that someday I'll be able
to explain what the hinge
in that process would be, right?
Not the ends of the seesaw.
We know what the sympathetic
nervous system is
and it's to wake us up and make us panic
or make us feel nicely alert and calm.
We know what puts someone
into sleep or a coma
or makes them feel relaxed.
But what shifts from one side
of the seesaw to the other
and the tightness of
that hinge seems to be
what you're describing,
that depression is sort
of a lack of control
over inner state so
that when I'm stressed,
I can't get myself out of it.
But when I'm feeling completely
collapsed with exhaustion,
I can't get out of bed and be motivated
to do the very things
that would help me get out of depression,
like a workout or social
connection or eat a quality meal,
these kinds of things.
So this is perhaps the first time
that I've ever heard
about a potential circuit
for the hinge, as I'm referring to it.
Does that make any sense at all?
- [Nolan] Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
- Okay, I just want to make sure
that I'm framing this
correctly in my mind.
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
And in some studies,
if you do the same identical stimulation
on the right dorsolateral,
you can get an acceleration.
You know, just kind of
further confirming this idea
of lateralization, right?
That it appears that even the
prefrontal cortex, you know,
cortical areas seem to be
lateralized in this way.
And, you know, it's less,
the right finding is more variable
depending upon the study.
The left's very consistent in this way.
So...
- So we've talked about
transcranial magnetic stimulation
for getting into these networks
and I also just want to take
a brief tangent and say,
'cause I've heard you say this before,
I think it's so vital what you're saying,
that it's really not
about stimulation of areas
or any specific brain area
or vagus nerve being important per se.
It's really about a network, a connection,
a series of connections.
I think that's really important
for people to understand
and is kind of a new
emerging theme really.
The other thing that to me
seems extremely important
for us to consider is
what are these lateral
prefrontal cortices doing?
Are they involved, for
instance, in sensation,
sensing the heart rate?
Are they involved in
thinking and planning?
And this gets down to
a very simple question
that I know a lot of
people have, which is,
can we talk ourselves out of depression?
If it's mild.
Can we talk ourselves into a manic state
or an excited state,
a positively excited state
that doesn't qualify as mania?
You know, other areas of the brain,
I think of is responsible for perception
or for motor control.
But here we are in this
mysterious frontal cortex area,
which people say executive
function, planning, et cetera.
Are we talking about thoughts?
Are we talking about structured thoughts
or are we talking about
dreamlike thoughts?
What in the world is going
on in the prefrontal cortex?
And here I spend my career in neuroscience
and I still can't really
understand what it's doing
and maybe it's doing 50 things.
- Yeah, no, it's a great question.
So, you know, to...
So one of the studies
that we've been working on
in addition to the depression
work is actually trying
to change trait hypnotizability.
So David Spiegel and I
have been working on this
and you know, he's found and
published this 10 years ago
that a different part of
the left dorsolateral is
functionally connected with
the dorsal anterior cingulate
with a lot of functional
connectivity in high hypnotizables
and not much in low hypnotizables.
And that's kind of a different sub-region
within this bigger brain region
we call left dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex
than the part that seems to be important
for regulating mood.
And so the left dorsolateral
seems to have connections
that are location specific
within the overall kind
of named brain region
that connect to various
parts of the cingulate
and seem to regulate it.
Right?
And so if you knock out
the left dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
and you have people do the
Stroop task, for instance,
which is a task where you
have, it's a simple task,
you probably know this.
You have people name the color of words.
And so if I look at one of the
cards that they'll show you,
it'll have the word red in red
and that's very easy and
that's called a congruent.
And then the incongruent
is red in the color blue
and you have to name,
you have to say the word,
you don't name the color.
- So you have to suppress a response.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And so, I'm sorry, you name the color
and you see the word
written in a different way.
And so basically if you stimulate in a way
that inhibits the left
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
or either one,
you can actually knock out
the ability to do that well
and it'll take longer for
people on the incongruent cards
to be able to name it.
And so they have a kind of a time delay
that's greater than they had
before they got stimulated.
So that's a part of the prefrontal cortex
that's different than the
part of the prefrontal cortex
that's involved in mood regulation.
The nice thing about TMS
is that you can go through
and you can find these areas
that are functionally defined
through brain imaging
and you can perturb them
and answer the question
you're talking about.
How do I understand this
part of the prefrontal cortex
and its function, this part?
And so we were able to
stimulate in an inhibitory way
within the left dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex
that's involved with this sort
of cognitive control area.
And we were able to knock that area out
and increase trait hypnotizability,
so people had greater hypnotizability
after they got active stimulation
versus when they got sham.
And so it suggests that that
brain circuit is involved
in the process of what therapeutic
hypnosis ends up being.
But it's a very different region
within the left dorsolateral than, say,
we do when we do these very
intensive stimulation approaches
to treat severe depression
and we're able to get
people out of depression.
You know, with the part
of the dorsolateral
that seems to be lower in the, you know,
kind of more lateral and
inferior on the DLPFC
and connected with this
subgenual anterior cingulate,
so the part of the anterior cingulate
that processes emotion.
- I'd like to take a quick break
and acknowledge one of our
sponsors, Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens, now called AG1,
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs.
I've been taking Athletic
Greens since 2012,
so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started
taking Athletic Greens,
and the reason I still
take Athletic Greens once
or usually twice a day is that
it gets to me the probiotics
that I need for gut health.
Our gut is very important.
It's populated by gut microbiota
that communicate with the
brain, the immune system,
and basically all the
biological systems of our body
to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health.
And those probiotics in
Athletic Greens are optimal
and vital for microbiotic health.
In addition, Athletic
Greens contains a number
of adaptogens, vitamins,
and minerals that make sure
that all of my foundational
nutritional needs are met
and it tastes great.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to AthleticGreens.com/huberman
and they'll give you
five free travel packs
that make it really easy
to mix up Athletic Greens
while you're on the road, in the car,
on the plane, et cetera.
And they'll give you a year
supply of vitamin D3K2.
Again, that's AthleticGreens.com/huberman
to get the five free travel packs
and the year supply of vitamin D3K2.
Based on what you told
us about the Stroop task
and the role of the prefrontal
cortex in the Stroop task,
to me the Stroop task is
a rule switching game.
You're saying in one moment,
the rule is you read
whatever the word says
and then you switch and then you say,
the rule now is you tell me
what color the word is written in
and you suppress whatever
it is the word says, okay?
- [Nolan] That's right.
- Okay, a rule in some
sense is, like that,
is a transiently adopted belief system.
So I could imagine that in depression,
which has all sorts of backstory to it,
that of course the
psychiatrist or psychologist
or friend can pull on that thread.
Like for instance,
somebody might believe that they are bad
or that they don't deserve love.
I'm trying to bring this
into the typical language
that they would talk about.
Or that they will never succeed.
Or that even if they keep succeeding,
it's just going to get harder and harder
and it will never feel good.
These are sort of rules
like the Stroop task.
At some level.
There are rules that are
more pervasive over time,
unfortunately.
But I could imagine that
if the PFC is also contains
some sort of maps or algorithms
related to rules of emotionality
or self representation or
things that we've heard,
I think there must be data out
there saying that, you know,
whatever we heard in middle school
when someone made fun of
us, we can remember that.
'Cause I can remember
things that people said
about a jacket I wore one day
or something in the fourth grade, crazy,
I didn't even like the jacket.
Now I think it was kind
of cool, but anyway.
The point being that we
have an intense memory
for these things to set up a
sort of rule or a question.
Like maybe I don't really know
how to dress, for instance.
Maybe that's why I always
wear the same black shirt.
But in all seriousness,
it seems like the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex is
in this amazing position to
access rules which are beliefs
and beliefs are rules,
and then for moments or
longer, to switch those rules.
And so for somebody who's depressed
to just simply look
themselves in the mirror
and say, "You are great,
you are fantastic,"
it feels like a lie if you
feel like garbage to say that.
It doesn't fit with the rule.
It's like saying that card is not red,
that card is green, when your
eyes tell you that it's red.
And it seems like there's
something about prefrontal cortex
that in principle gives
flexibility to rules
based on what we know
about the Stroop task.
So given its connectivity,
can we assume that the
talk therapy that occurs
in the psychiatrist
office or with a friend
or through journaling out something,
because we do know that
reporting things about trauma
or difficult circumstances
or the rules that we contain
and tend to hide inside of us
about how we feel miserable
about ourselves or anything really,
that in rescripting that,
that somehow it allows us
to do a sort of Stroop task
on our beliefs.
Is that a tremendous leap?
I'm just really trying to
frame this in the context
of what I and most people
think of as depression.
- [Nolan] Yeah, totally.
- Because the network components
are vitally important,
but I guess what I'm
trying to figure out is
like what are the algorithms
that govern prefrontal cortex?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So in a kind of standard
cognitive behavioral
therapy session, right,
what the therapist is trying
to do is identify those beliefs
and you know, kind of
determine how fixed they are,
you know, if they're
flexible as you're saying,
and then help folks to find
another explanation for them
and to kind of reintegrate that
potential other explanation
into their memory system, right?
Where I think TMS is really
interesting, actually,
we had a lot of patients who've told me,
like my therapist told me that
I wasn't trying hard enough
in therapy, and you know,
and I really am trying hard,
but these are, you know, moderate,
pretty severe depressed patients.
And as soon as we get them
well with the TMS approaches,
you know, kind of rapid five day approach
and the next week we come in and see them
and they'll say,
"You know what I did all weekend is
I looked at my therapy books
and now I can understand it."
And so, you know, I
actually see TMS as a way
of having kind of exogenous
sorts of cognitive functions
that in milder forms of depression
we can pull off with psychotherapy.
You know, this idea of being able
to kind of turn that prefrontal cortex on
and have it govern these deeper regions.
In depression,
the deeper regions govern
the prefrontal cortex.
They precede the prefrontal
cortex timing-wise.
And we've got some data in review now
where we're seeing that
in depressed individuals
that are responsive to
our rapid TMS approach,
what we call
Stanford Accelerated Intelligent
Neuromodulation Therapy,
or SNT, or SAINT, if you look at the brain
before people get this, they
will have a temporal delay
where the cingulate is
in front of the DLPFC.
And in people that are
normal healthy controls,
no depression, the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex is
temporally in front of
the anterior cingulate.
With effective treatment, we
can flip the timing of things
so the dorsolateral is in front
of the anterior cingulate,
just like in a normal person.
- So you're not talking
about obviously physically
moving these structures,
you're talking about in
time, their activation.
So in one case,
it's like the coach telling
the player what to do.
And the other is like a player
telling the coach what to do.
And you restore order to the game.
- You restore order to the game.
And what it looks like is
depression, to your point,
is a bunch of kind of spontaneous content
that's semi-volitional that's
being kind of generated
out of this conflict detection system.
The cingulate seems to sense conflict
and kind of feed that information,
gets overactive in depression.
And then in depression, it
looks like the left dorsolateral
does not sufficiently clamp down on it.
And what therapy appears to
do is to kind of restore that.
What we see with TMS over that region is
that we just exogenously
do the same sort of thing.
We restore the governance
of the left dorsolateral
over the cingulate area,
and that is correlated
with treatment improvement.
So the degree in which you can re-time,
re-regulate in time the left dorsolateral
over the cingulate,
the more of an antidepressant
effect you have.
- Can we therefore say in crude terms
that the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex really is
the governor of how we
interpret physiological signals
and spontaneous thoughts?
- It places a lens
that the rest of the
brain sees things through.
And you can do these experiments
where you can put a normal
healthy control person
in the scanner and you can make them feel
like they have a loss of control
and then you can see that
region come offline, right?
So you can experimentally
manipulate the system,
and so kind of buffing it up,
it's like TMS is almost like
exercise for the brain, right?
You're kind of exercising this
region over and over again
with a physiologically relevant signal
and kind of turning that system on.
And what's interesting,
I think really interesting
for this show is to, you know,
we had a couple of folks, you know,
probably five or six folks that
have actually told me this,
where if they remit
early enough in the week,
we have this very dense
stimulation approach
where we can stimulate
people really rapidly
over a five day block.
We don't discriminate when they get better
to when they stop.
So if they get better on day one,
we still give them the other four days
because it's in the protocol to do that.
And we can't, we're getting to a point
where we can tell how
long it's going to take,
but we're not there yet.
And so, you know,
every time somebody gets
better at day one or two,
at the beginning when we first
started doing this, we'd say,
you know, we're not sure, you know,
we think this is safe to keep going,
but you know, what do you want to do?
And everybody was like,
no, I want to keep going.
And so, you know, by Wednesday,
they're like totally zeroed
out on the depression scales,
you know, even better than
most people walking around.
Like really no anxiety,
no depression or anything.
By Thursday, the first
guy that told me this,
he came in and he said,
"You know, I was driving back to my hotel
and I decided to go to the
beach and I just sat there
and I was totally present
in the present moment
for an hour."
And he's like,
"I read about this in
my mindfulness books,
but I experienced it last night
and I've never experienced
anything like this before."
And I was like, hmm, that's interesting,
but kind of wasn't sure.
And then I didn't tell
obviously any more patients
about that, and then about five
over the last couple of years,
when they remit early in the week,
by the end of the week they're
like going to the beach
and they're like totally
having what people describe
as a pretty mindful present
moment sort of experience,
which is really interesting,
you know, what that is.
I mean, I don't have full on
scientific data to tell you,
but it's just an
interesting anecdote, right?
That folks, when you push
them through this point
of feeling kind of clinically well
that some people end up
reporting this additional set
of features.
- You mentioned the cingulate
and the anterior cingulate in particular.
Because now I feel like for
the first time in my career,
I have some sense of
what prefrontal cortex
might actually be doing
besides providing a bumper
for the rest of the brain.
The cingulate, it seems, is
a more primitive structure
in the sense that ideally
it's under the regulation
of this top down control
from prefrontal cortex,
but what's mapped in the cingulate?
And for the non neuroscientist
out there, when I say mapped,
if we were to put someone in a scanner
and focus in on cingulate or
put an electrode in there,
what makes the neurons in there fire?
What sorts of things in
the body and in the mind
and out in the world light up,
for lack of a better phrase,
the cingulate?
What does the cingulate like?
- Yeah, yeah, so that Stroop task,
those incongruent word color associations,
the dorsal part of that.
For obsessive compulsive
disorder patients,
certain kind of triggers.
You'll see some of the neural
imaging studies will point
to anterior cingulate.
In the kind of very crude
psychosurgery world 50 years ago,
the anterior cingulotomy was a way
of treating obsessive
compulsive disorder, right?
'Cause that area seems to
be overactive in people
who are experiencing
obsessive compulsive disorder.
You can kind of walk, the
cingulate wraps around, you know,
this white matter track like
bundles, it wraps around that.
And so there's a part that's above that,
around that, and below that,
and depending upon how much
of the conflict task has
an emotional component,
the more ventral and
subgenual that activation is.
So the dorsal part of the
anterior cingulate seems
to be kind of more of a pure cognitive,
maybe obsessive compulsive
disorder sort of area.
Whereas when you start getting
into mood sorts of triggers,
like facial expression conflicts
where you're supposed to,
you know, there's an emotional Stroop task
where you show the word happy
and then you have a face
of a person that looks mad,
then that's another way
of having the same sort
of Stroop conflict.
That seems to be more perigenual,
subgenual areas, right?
So you can kind of,
you can trigger the
cingulate based off the level
of emotional valence
from none down to a lot.
And that seems to be how it's distributed.
There are, you know, heart
rate kind of components to it
and autonomic components in there too.
There's something called akinetic mutism,
you know, I'm a board
certified neuropsychiatrist,
behavioral neurologist,
and I've seen, you know,
a lot of these what we call
zebra cases in neurology
where people have, you know,
these unusual neurological presentations
and one of them is akinetic mutism.
So if you have a glioma sitting
in the inner hemispheric fissure
and kind of having
pressure on the cingulate,
people can get into an almost
catatonic looking state
where they kind of get
stuck and they don't speak.
And so that tells you something
about how the cingulate
works as well, right?
It's like if it's not functioning,
then people have a hard
time kind of connecting
with reality.
It seems to need to be constantly online
to be able to interact
with the exterior world.
- Is it involved in some
of the dissociative states
that sometimes people
who are very stressed
or depressed experience?
You said catatonia being an extreme one,
but I know someone for instance,
that when they get really stressed,
and it can even be if
someone yells at them
or even if someone's angry with them
or they perceive
someone's angry with them,
there's a developmental backstory
to why they likely feel this way,
they sort of just kind of can't...
This is a high functioning
individual normally,
and they just sort of can't function.
They can't complete
simple things like email
or groceries or things for a short while.
It's almost like a catatonia
and they refer to it as
a dissociative state.
Do you see that in depression?
And I mean, we're speculating here
as to whether or not that
involves a cingulate,
but what you're saying holds
a lot of salience for me
in thinking about this example.
- Yeah, yeah.
There's, so you see catatonia
as an extreme outcome
of depression and sometimes schizophrenia
and other illnesses.
Dissociation is an extreme outcome,
or even in some cases,
a less extreme outcome
of PTSD and trauma.
And you know,
and it's also a phenomenon
that happens naturally
in some people that are
highly hypnotizable.
And so if you ask David Spiegel,
he'd say that, you know,
some of the work that
he's been working on is
around posterior cingulate in
the capacity to disassociate.
But yeah, you know, with our
stimulation approach to DLPFC,
dorsal anterior cingulate,
one of the subscales
that moved the most was
the dissociative subscale
for hypnotizability.
So even in a normal individual, you know,
you see that change
in that kind of experience
of dissociation.
- I am highly hypnotizable.
David's hypnotized me a number of times.
In fact, we have a clip of that
on our Huberman Live clips channel.
I've always, well, always.
Starting at my early teens,
I started exploring hypnosis.
I'm extremely hypnotizable.
And self hypnosis or assisted hypnosis.
I don't know that I ever go
into dissociative states.
I'll try and avoid forcing you
into running a clinical session right now,
but to assess anything like that.
But this brings about something
really interesting, I think,
which is I'm aware that some
of the more popular emerging
treatments for depression
include things like ketamine,
which is a dissociative anesthetic.
Is that right?
- Yep.
- And my assumption is that
as a dissociative anesthetic,
that it leads to dissociative states
where people can sort of
third person themselves
and feel somewhat distanced
from their emotions.
I've also been hearing that
there are emerging treatments,
psilocybin being one of them,
but some other treatments,
MDMA, et cetera, that we'll
parse each of these in detail,
that lead to the exact opposite state
during the effect of the drug,
which is a highly engaged emotionality
and heart rate and sense of self.
And can also lead to relief of depression.
Now, whether or not this, again,
reflects that depression
is many conditions
as opposed to just one,
or whether or not somehow tickling
or in some cases pushing really
hard on the opposite ends
of the scale really matter,
I am absolutely fascinated,
and again, also perplexed by this.
Why would it be that a drug
that induces dissociative states
and a drug taken separately
that induces hyper-associative
states would lead to relief
of the same condition?
- Yeah, no, that's a great question.
Yeah, so for ketamine, you know,
the level of dissociation
appears to be correlated
with the therapeutic effect.
It appears to be necessary
but not sufficient
to produce an antidepressant effect.
And so folks that don't have
any psychological change
from the ketamine or don't
experience any dissociation
typically tend to have less
potent antidepressant effects
from ketamine.
We did a study a couple of years ago,
it was really interesting.
So we gave folks naltrexone,
which is an opiate antagonist,
mu and kappa opiate receptor antagonist.
And we gave folk, the same individuals,
a pill of that or a pill of placebo,
and they had no idea which
one they were getting.
- Was this low dose naltrexone?
- [Nolan] 50 milligrams,
so it's pretty high dose.
- Okay.
- Yeah, and so we gave a typical
ketamine therapeutic dose,
and then we gave 50 milligrams
of naltrexone or placebo.
And then in the same individuals,
we gave two infusions, one
with each of those conditions.
And if they had an antidepressant effect,
we waited until they relapsed
and then we gave 'em the other condition.
And then we looked to see what effect
of blocking the opioid receptor,
what effect would you see
on the antidepressant effect
of blocking the opioid receptor
with the idea that if
ketamine works the way
that a lot of researchers
at the time thought that it,
you know, completely worked in,
which is the glutamate system,
then you would have no
effect of naltrexone.
'Cause naltrexone just interacts
with the opioid system.
It doesn't do anything
with any other systems.
Ketamine has a lot of
effects over, you know,
it has clear opioid effects in mice
in various ways of looking at that,
and an MDA receptor antagonism
and glutamate effects.
And so if it's just that
the glutamate part is
the part driving the
antidepressant effect,
you shouldn't have any difference
in the antidepressant effect
between the two conditions.
If, however, the antidepressant
effect is primarily is
the opioid properties of
ketamine are necessary
for the antidepressant effect,
then you should have a loss
of antidepressant effect
during the ketamine plus
naltrexone condition
that you observed in the
ketamine plus placebo condition.
And what we saw was that
there was a dramatic blockade
of the antidepressant effect
when naltrexone was present.
Yeah, in the people that
had an antidepressant effect
with ketamine plus placebo alone.
And then some friends of mine
did a TMS study with pain
and they stimulated
over the left dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex
and they gave IV naloxone,
which works basically the
same way as naltrexone,
and they were able to block
the anti-pain effects of TMS
with a opiate blocker.
So this idea that another kind
of convergent point, right?
This idea that the opioid
receptor may have a role
in mood regulation.
What's also interesting
is if you look at people
that are getting a total knee operation,
very painful operation, right?
You know, total knee replacement
and you age, sex, you know,
everything match the individuals
that are going through that.
But you have a group of people
that don't have depression
and a group of people
that do have depression.
The presence of depression triples
the oral opioid dose by day four, right?
- That's required.
- That's required to cover the pain
but what may be happening is
it's not just treating physical pain,
may be treating emotional
pain as well, right?
At least transiently,
it seems to have an antidepressant effect.
Chronically, it seems to have
a very pro-depressant effect.
It can make people treatment resistant.
But, you know, it's an
interesting phenomenon.
But yeah, the opioid system
seems to be pretty involved.
But what's interesting there
with the ketamine trial is
that we didn't see any
effect on the dissociation.
And so the dissociation
was the same each time.
So the psychological effect
of what we call the trip
or the kind of dissociative effect
where people are having a
psychological phenomenon
from ketamine, that was
identical both times.
And so it kind of, it
also challenged this idea
that the psychological experience
of the psychedelic effect
may be all that's necessary
to produce an effect
and that the pharmacology doesn't matter
as long as you can achieve that state.
And so, you know,
we think we pretty
clearly debunked that idea
that the underlying pharmacology
and the state, you know,
seem to be important.
We don't know for sure if you can,
a lot of people are working on this,
if you can take out, you know,
essentially the psychological effect
and still have a drug that
works to treat the illness
that you're trying to target.
And there was a mouse study out this week
where they had an LSD analog
and they were able to see
some animal level data
to suggest that could be true.
But until we figure that out in humans,
it's kind of to be determined.
But it is curious, right?
Being able to kind of use
experimental manipulations
to try to separate, you know,
some of these phenomenon apart
and really understand what's doing what.
- It's so critical
and it's so critical to
the other conversation
that we'll surely get to,
which is the progression of psychedelics
from illicit illegal drugs
to clinically validated,
and presumably at some point,
either decriminalized or legal drugs,
which has not yet happened,
at least not in the US.
But just to make sure that
people are getting this
and how crucial this is.
What we're really talking
about here is the fact that,
you know, if somebody takes a
multi gram dose of psilocybin
or somebody takes MDMA
or they take ketamine
and they experience
relief from their trauma,
their depression, their addiction,
or any number of the other things
that indeed those compounds
have be shown to be useful for
in certain contexts, clinically
supported, et cetera.
There's this like
gravitational pull to the idea
that, oh, it was the hallucinations.
It was the dissociative state.
It was the feeling of connectedness.
And what we're really saying is
that while that certainly could be true,
it may be the case that a major
source of the positive shift
that occurs after the
effect of the drug is
some underlying biology,
like shifts in the mu opioid receptor,
a la your experiments with naltrexone,
or a change in the
underlying neuromodulation
that had anywhere from nothing
to something to do with the real shift.
And I know there's a group up at UC Davis
that published a paper in
nature about a year ago
also looking at this is a
chemistry lab essentially,
modifying psychedelics
to remove the hallucinogenic properties,
the mood altering properties,
and actually seeing some
pretty impressive effects
and shifts in mood after
the drug wears off.
And I know this gets people
upset when they hear it.
This gets a lot of people upset really.
Because people think, oh no,
it's the intense experience that matters.
But in fact, that may
not be the case at all.
In fact, it's so powerful for people
that sometimes I liken it
in my mind to, you know,
it's like the birth of a new child
and it's such an incredible experience
and then people feel so much connection.
And then they sort of
connect the experience
of the actual birth to the connection,
when in fact they're,
that's true it turns out,
but there are a bunch of
other things happening too.
That's simply the reflection of the fact
that you're holding a child
and the pheromonal effects et cetera.
So anyway, I think it's very important
that these different
variables be figured out.
Along those lines, I want to make sure
that before we dive a bit deeper
into ketamine and psilocybin,
that we do touch on really important topic
that has been in the press a lot lately,
which is SSRI, selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors.
'Cause we can't really have
a discussion about depression
without talking about SSRIs.
And then I want to circle back
to ketamine and psilocybin.
It seems that there are now data
that essentially state
that there's no direct link
between serotonin levels and depression.
Although my understanding is
that the SSRIs are powerfully effective
for certain forms of
obsessive compulsive disorder
and may also be effective
for treatment of depression,
but it may again be through
some effect unrelated
to serotonin itself.
Is that right?
And how should we think about SSRIs?
Are they useful, are they not useful?
What's going on with
SSRIs in your patients
and in other people as well?
- Yeah, so the experiment
that I described a bit ago
around the naltrexone and
ketamine was the first time
I'm aware of where we were
able to essentially eliminate
an antidepressant's effect
by using a second drug
as a kind of a blockade.
And it highlights a bigger issue, right?
The issue that we haven't had a good way
of really understanding
how these drugs work.
And so it's the difference.
I think a lot of the controversy there is
that it's been been difficult, I think,
for folks to see that
something can on one hand work
and on the other hand, we
don't know how it works, right?
And so SSRIs clearly work.
You know, many, many meta analyses
kind of proving that out, right?
That in a subpopulation of individuals,
they achieve great benefit
from depression, you know,
for depression, for obsessive
compulsive disorder,
for generalized anxiety
disorder, panic, you know,
all these things,
you can see an improvement
in those symptoms
with what we call SSRIs
or selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors.
The issue there is
that these selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors end up
blocking the reuptake of serotonin
and leaving the serotonin, you know,
in this kind of in between,
between two neurons for a while
and allowing for more
serotonin to kind of be there.
The issue is that they don't
work immediately, right?
So they don't work like the
same day you start taking them.
And that suggests that
probably it's not exactly
the serotonin being in there
that's directly driving it,
that it's much more likely
that it may have some, say,
brain plasticity effects, right?
We know that things like brain
derived neurotrophic factor
get upregulated with chronic
oral antidepressant use.
And so that's kind of the idea
is that these things work,
but what's powerful,
and I think with the
authors of this paper,
this extremely controversial paper,
were in part trying to say was
that there's not a deficit of serotonin.
You're not born with what people
call a chemical imbalance.
And psychiatry's known this.
This is not actually new
information, anybody, you know,
and it's kind of a rehashing
of a bunch of information
we've known for a while now,
but in the lay press,
it's kind of hit in a
way that it didn't seem
to grab attention before
with previous publications.
But this idea that this chemical
imbalance idea is wrong.
I really think that part's
important because I think that,
you know, for a while, I think psychiatry,
you know, what I'll call
psychiatry 1.0, right?
This kind of idea of
Freud and psychotherapy
and its origins.
It was a lot around, you know, your family
and those experiences and
psychotherapy kind of going in
and correcting or helping
you to figure out,
and you know, you being able to see,
or people hear you so that
you can eventually come
to the conclusion of certain cognitions
that aren't helping you, right?
And there's a huge importance there,
but there's a history where, you know,
things like the schizophrenogenic
mother and all of that,
you know, that was a concept
at some point, right?
And so we've transitioned
from that to, you know,
for a long time the chemical imbalance,
which I'll call psychiatry 2.0.
You know,
this idea that there's
something chemically missing
and I think that the
trouble there for a patient
who's not a physician,
who's not someone who's steeped
in these sorts of ideas,
who's, you know, more of kind of a person,
kind of average American out there, right,
is that it's sending a message
of there's something missing with me,
whether it be my experiences
I had no control over
when I was a child or
a chemical in my brain.
What I think is really powerful with TMS,
you know, really powerful with TMS,
and even powerful with
the psychedelic story is
it's saying something different.
You know, TMS works and
there's no serotonin coming in
or out of the brain, right?
And we're doing a rapid form of TMS
that works in one to five days.
There's no, it's very unlikely
that there's some long
term kind of upregulation
of serotonin that's driving that.
So our work actually kind of pushes back
on this serotonin hypothesis
as being kind of the center of depression
because it says, look,
we're not giving anybody any serotonin.
We're simply turning
these brain regions on
and we're focused on the circuitry.
And that's psychiatry 3.0.
It's not just like neuromodulation.
Neuromodulations are
really nice, you know,
use case for psychiatry 3.0
'cause it's a way to focally
and directly perturb brain regions
in whatever modality you're using.
But you know, there are a lot of groups
that are actually doing
neuroimaging before and after,
and they're able to see
circuit level changes
for something like psilocybin or ketamine
long after the drug is gone, right?
Suggesting in those same
brain regions converge,
so the subgenual default
mode network connection
that we see is changing
with our Stanford neuromodulation
therapy technique.
It's that same set of brain regions
that ketamine and
psilocybin seem to act on,
act on these connections
between brain networks
that seem to shift.
And so it refocuses the story
on something that's highly correctable.
And it's basically electrophysiology
and it's basically kind
of recalibrating a circuit
that is recalibrate-able instead
of I have something missing
or I have some set of
experiences early in life
that are going to forever trap me
in these psychiatric diagnoses.
And so it kind of challenges that idea.
And I think that's what's so
powerful about psychiatry 3.0.
This idea of focusing on the
circuit because it gets us
into thinking about psychiatry
and psychiatric illnesses
as something that are recoverable.
People can get better.
People, you know, we've seen
with our TMS techniques,
we've seen with some of the
psychedelic work that we've done
where people are actually
in normal levels of mood
for sustained periods of time or-
- Within five days.
- Within five or less days.
And in the case of the psychedelics,
within a few days, right?
So we can get people out of these states.
They're totally well,
there's no drug in their
system in that point,
in the case of the psychedelics.
It was never a drug in their
system, in the case of TMS.
And it just tells us that it's fixable.
It's just like the heart.
It's just like an arrhythmia in the heart.
It's just like, you know,
these other illnesses,
that it's like a broken leg.
We can go in and do something
and we can get somebody better.
Then I think what's empowering
and what a lot of patients
have told me is they say,
you know, some people will
relapse and need more stimulation
or need more psychedelics
or whatever it is,
but they'll tell me, I've
relapsed and I'm depressed again,
but I'll never think
about killing myself again
because I know that if I
go get stimulated again,
it improves, it gets better.
I will be able to
reachieve it and I can't.
And I don't fear that
I'm chronically broken.
I don't fear that the
chemical imbalance is
still imbalanced.
I don't fear that these
things that I couldn't control
in my childhood, you know,
are going to be there and
drive this problem forever.
And I think that's what's
so powerful about this.
- [Andrew] The sense of control.
- The sense of control, the sense of...
They're not doing the
stimulation themselves.
They're not administering the drug
in these trials themselves.
And they probably never will.
These will probably be medical treatments.
But they are choosing to do it.
And in that sense, they are in control.
- Yeah, I have a good
friend, I won't out him
for reasons that'll
become clear in a moment,
who was quite obese and
lost a lot of weight
and was really proud of himself.
And then I guess we could
say he sort of relapsed
in a sense.
Not all the way, but far along.
But his tone around it was very different.
He knew he had accomplished
what his goal once before.
He was disappointed in himself,
but he knew exactly why he had relapsed.
It was very clear.
He had essentially relapsed
to the previous set
of eating behaviors and
lack of exercise behaviors
and has now brought himself back again.
And it just resonates with
your story that, you know,
once somebody understands they can do it
because they've been there before,
this idea again of considering
new rules, that there's...
And that brings me to this
question about psychedelics
and frankly the altered thinking
and perception that occurs
in high dose psilocybin clinical sessions.
It seems that the disordered thinking,
even though it could be random, right?
Hearing colors and seeing sounds is
always the kind of cliche statement
of the Timothy Leary area.
Also, you know, right there,
that's a Stroop task of sorts.
It's a synesthesia, it's a
combining of perceptions,
but it's sort of Stroop task-ish
in that it's a new set of rules
for the same stuff, right?
And many people do report improvements
in trauma related
symptomology and depression,
as I understand it from my
read of the clinical trials,
after taking psilocybin.
Because during those sessions,
something comes to mind spontaneously.
As you and I were talking about
earlier, they will report,
for instance, a new way
of seeing the old problem.
And the old problem could be
the voice that they're no good,
nothing will ever work out,
or could be even more subtle than that.
So that raises two questions.
One is about the basic
functioning of the human brain,
which is why do you think
the brain would ever hold on
to rules that don't serve us well?
That's one question.
And then the second question is,
what is it about psilocybin
and related molecules
in terms of their neurochemistry,
in terms of the ways they
disrupt thinking and feeling,
et cetera, during the session
that allow this novel rule
consideration phenomenon?
- Yeah.
So the first question,
I think it's an evolutionary
neurobiology answer, right?
I think that at the individual
person level, you know,
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
that when we're really stressed out,
some of us want to eat more, right?
At the individual person level
'cause it's like,
that's not particularly
that good for my health
in the long term.
But if you think about it, like, you know,
in some 500 years ago, 1,000 years ago,
if I'm highly stressed out,
it's most likely that I'm
about to not have food
at some point and I
should eat a bunch of food
that is high fat, high
sugar, high carb food
to put on weight for that next phase
where in this stress I may be in battle
and I don't have food
and I have enough fuel on board, right?
And so we end up being a result
of probably a lot of biology
that's not that useful
in the modern era.
And I think in the brain for,
say, let's say PTSD, right?
A lot of veterans come back
and they experience these PTSD symptoms
and they're not at all
useful back home, right?
You know, they hear some loud noise
and all of a sudden they're behind a car
or they're behind a, you
know, I've heard of folks,
you know, jump and run behind a trashcan
or whatever in the middle of San Francisco
when they hear a loud noise.
But if you put them
back in the battlefield.
- [Andrew] Highly adaptive.
- That's highly adaptive, right?
And so I think what's
interesting is that we,
in the absence of using
substances like psychedelics,
end up having these
very persistent memories
that are attached to
negatively balanced emotion,
predominantly, as you were saying earlier,
the jacket in elementary school, you know,
I had various things like
that for me too, right?
You remember these things.
And we hold onto those things
from I think an evolutionary
neurobiology standpoint,
but what seems to, for whatever reason,
kind of alleviate that
are these substances,
some new like MDMA,
some that have been around
for thousands of years,
like psilocybin, and used as
a sacrament in traditions,
seem to have a therapeutic effect.
It seems to be pretty long
lasting for these phenomenon.
And so it's just curious, right?
It's curious that in the absence of that,
these things will keep going on and on,
but in the presence of that exposure,
then all of a sudden you see
a resolution of the problem.
And we have some work now
we're treating folks with,
Navy SEALs, and the data's
still being analyzed.
But the anecdotes that
we're getting, right,
are folks are coming
back and they're saying
it's finally gone, right?
These set of PTSD
symptoms are finally gone.
And so this idea that for whatever reason,
going into what's probably
a highly plastic state
like we were talking about earlier,
upregulation of brain
derived neurotrophic factor
in the case of ibogaine, glial
derived neurotrophic factor,
this highly plastic state and the ability
to kind of re-experience memories.
And then as you know,
we always reconsolidate a
memory when we bring it back up,
we always reconsolidate it.
But reconsolidating it in that
state, for whatever reason,
may drive a therapeutic effect.
And, you know, the jury's still out.
I would say that I'm kind of an agnostic
to what tool I'm using kind of guy.
Like my business is to find
treatments that help people.
And so I'm much more like
pragmatic about it, you know.
If this sort of thing, which
has a lot of cultural baggage,
but if this sort of thing
ultimately ends up being therapeutic,
if we can design trials
that convince me and others
that it is, then we
should absolutely use it.
You know?
And if it doesn't, then we
clearly shouldn't use it, right?
And I think that's a big question
the field's going to have to work out.
We have a hard time blinding these trials
because the placebo condition is not easy
to pull off, obviously.
- A placebo for a psilocybin
journey is hard to imagine.
- We've got, you know, we've
been thinking about this
and maybe that ketamine study
that I was talking about earlier,
if we could give people
naltrexone and ketamine,
maybe that's a good sort of
placebo condition, right?
'Cause we know that we can block any
of the actual antidepressant
effects of ketamine,
they still have an experience, you know.
And so that's one way of doing it.
But thinking about ways to do that
and really kind of proving this out.
And that's been, yeah,
I think that's been kind of central
to the way I've been thinking about this.
But yeah, I think there's the
work that's been done so far,
the first psilocybin trial,
the first MDMA trial was published
in "Nature Medicine" recently.
- And what do those generally say?
I mean, that they are effective
for a number of people
after one session, two sessions?
What's sort of the general contour of?
And let's start with psilocybin and MDMA.
- Yeah, so MDMA appears to,
in one to a few MDMA sessions,
have an anti PTSD effect
that seems to be, you know,
outside of the kind of
standard assumed levels
of PTSD improvement that you
can observe in individuals
with this level of PTSD, right?
So what we call the effect size,
which is essentially like a effect size,
the measure that allows for you
to compare different
treatments to each other
for different conditions
that are, you know, agnostic
to what the actual illness is.
You know, the effect
size is there, you know,
approach effect size is the
things that are pretty effective
like antacids for heartburn, right?
And you see that with MDMA treatment.
- So does that mean that
for people that have trauma,
and again, we're talking
about in a clinical setting,
they take a one or two doses of MDMA.
I think the standard maps
dose is 150 to 175 milligrams.
Again, doing this with
a physician, et cetera,
control clinical trial, legal.
- [Nolan] Yep, exactly.
- They do it once or twice.
And broadly speaking,
what percentage of people
who had trauma report
feeling significant relief
from their trauma afterward?
- It's about 2/3 of people had
a clinically significant
change in their PTSD.
- That's impressive.
- [Nolan] Which is impressive, right?
- And how long lasting was that?
I mean, these trials were
ended pretty recently, so...
- Yeah, it appears to last for a while.
In the earlier trials where
they followed people out,
it seemed to last for
kind of in the years range
for some people.
And so it's, you know,
it's pretty compelling.
Psilocybin, you know, and
contrast that with ketamine,
which only on average lasts
about a week and a half
for a single infusion,
so it's a much shorter.
- So they have to get
repeated infusions of ketamine
every 10 days or so?
Forever?
- For some people, or they end up getting
like a bunch of doses
for a couple of weeks.
And then for some people
that seems to last a while.
You know, that's where I
think the psilocybin story
for depression and the
MDMA story for PTSD seemed
more interesting to me.
- So for psilocybin, what
is the rough percentages on,
and this would be relief not from trauma,
but from depression, correct?
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
So it's, you know, in open label studies,
it's closer to like half
to 2/3 of people end up
getting better depending upon their level
of treatment resistance.
In the blinded trials it was
more like 1/3 or so of people,
you know, experienced relief.
And this is, you know, this is
a press release of the data,
you know, and so it
hasn't, to my knowledge,
it hasn't been published yet.
And so I'm looking forward
to seeing the full paper
on that one.
But it, you know, separated from placebo
and looks pretty good as well.
It looks like it's, you know,
the first of two trials
that need to be done
to get this thing approved
for treatment resistant depression.
And so that stuff looks good.
- In terms of MDMA, for
many years it was reported
in the popular press
and there was a paper published in science
that MDMA was neurotoxic,
that it would kill serotonin neurons.
This was what was always said.
Then I saw another paper
published in science
that wasn't a retraction
of the previous paper,
but rather was a second
paper in the same group
that essentially admitted
that the first time around,
they had injected these
monkeys with not MDMA,
but with methamphetamine, which
is known to be neurotoxic.
So it was kind of a
public admittance of oops
or like really big screw up, so oops,
but never a retraction
and then never really a
publicly acknowledged correction
in the popular press.
So it seems that in the
appropriate dosage range,
and with these one or two sessions,
my assumption, and this
again is an assumption,
tell me if I'm right or wrong here,
is that MDMA is not neurotoxic
for serotonergic neurons
at appropriate doses and
with appropriate sourcing,
et cetera.
- So it was an interesting study that,
I think the guy's name is
Halpern, last name's Halpern.
- [Andrew] Not Casey Halpern.
- Not, different Halpern.
I think Joshua Halpern,
I'm blanking on his first name, but...
- Casey Halpern was a
guest on this podcast
and is a former colleague
of ours at Stanford,
who unfortunately we lost to
University of Pennsylvania
and maybe someday we'll bring him back.
- Yeah, that's right.
So this individual, you know,
received some NIH funding
to actually, NIDA, you know,
National Institute for Drug Abuse funding
to explore individuals of
the Mormon faith in Utah
who partake in only MDMA.
So the way this works is
that MDMA happened kind of after a lot
of the religious documents were developed.
And so MDMA isn't on the
prohibited drug list.
- The banned substance list.
- [Nolan] The banned substance list.
- I have some good friends who are LDS.
- Yeah, great people.
I do as well, you know,
just a kind of set of facts, you know.
And so these folks only
use MDMA but they don't,
they're not, you know,
the problem with some people using drugs,
they're poly substance users, right?
So you can't say it's the MDMA
if they've also taken other psychedelics
and they've taken opiates
and they've taken cocaine,
and you have this picture
where you can't really
tease out that problem.
But with this, right,
it was just individuals that
were part of the Mormon faith.
And so they were kind of purist
in the sense they only used MDMA
and he confirmed all of that.
And it was a brilliant study, right?
Because then he was able to go in
and look at their cognitive profiles
versus individuals of the same
geography, the same faith,
all of that, that
happened to not take MDMA
and found there were no
neurocognitive differences.
- So does that mean that
it was not damaging?
- It was not damaging.
It's hard to know because to
really do this study well,
you'd have to track these folks down
before they ever took
MDMA and do a pre-post
and compare to people that didn't.
But, you know, this is
about as good of a study
as you can do, given the situation,
to be able to check this out.
Additionally, when I
was back in Charleston
and working in the Medical
University of South Carolina,
one of my mentors there, Dr. Wagner,
was a neuropsychologist at MUSC
and he was also the neuropsychologist
for the early MDMA trials.
And so he did all the
neurocognitive batteries
for individuals pre-post
and similarly did not see any changes
in neurocognitive profiles
in a negative way.
And so, you know,
there's data from experimental
patients receiving this.
There's data from people
that are chronic users,
you know, who only take MDMA.
And that combination of data suggests
that there's certainly no apparent risk
in the kind of one to
two to three dose range.
And it's probably unlikely
that at least, you know,
modest dose exposure over
a lifetime doesn't appear
to have a profound neurocognitive
damaging effect, yeah.
- Interesting.
Yeah, I know that sourcing
is key and we're here,
we're talking about clinical
trials where purity is assured.
And you know,
years ago when so-called
raves were really popular,
maybe they're still
popular, never been to one,
so wouldn't know if
they're happening or not.
That's how in the know I am.
But it was clear that, you know,
testing for purity was important
because sometimes the drugs are made
such that there are contaminants
like methamphetamine,
which we know is highly neurotoxic.
I think that one reason why people think
that MDMA might be neurotoxic
is the reported drop in energy
or sort of feeling fatigued
for a few days afterward.
I spoke to a physician colleague of ours
who said that that very
likely has something to do
with the surge in prolactin
that arrives subsequent
to the big dopamine surge
that occurs in MDMA.
And I mention that because I
know a number of people talk
about serotonin depletion
after taking MDMA.
He has it in mind that
while that could be true,
it's likely that anytime
somebody takes something
or does something where there's
a huge lift in dopamine,
that there's very likely a
huge compensatory increase
in prolactin that follows
and prolactin has a
kind of sedative effect,
numbing effect on mood
and libido, et cetera,
that eventually also wears off.
Does that make sense
to you as a physician?
- Yeah, it makes sense.
I mean, you know,
the difference between,
say, MDMA and psilocybin is
that MDMA is kind of an
amphetamine of sorts, right?
So it has effects in dopamine
and psilocybin's, you
know, pretty neutral,
and you know, maybe a little
bit of dopamine effects,
but kind of much more of a
serotonergic focused drug.
And so yeah,
I think you're going to see kind
of a different profile after.
And that makes, I
haven't heard that story,
but that makes sense to me too.
- Since you mentioned psilocybin,
let's talk a little bit
about the neurochemistry of psilocybin.
As a serotonergic agent, my
understanding is it operates
on these, is it the 5HT
serotonin 2C receptor?
- 2A.
- 2A, excuse me.
2A and receptors.
And that I've seen a
bunch of different reports
in terms of what it's
actually doing to the brain
while people are under
the effects of the drug.
And this is important
for us to segment out
because there are the effects that happen
while people are under the influence
and then the more long lasting effects.
But some of the effects I've
heard about are, for instance,
and tell me again if
these are right or wrong,
that there is increased
activation of lateral connection,
sort of broader areas of
the brain being coactive
than would normally occur.
Maybe that explains some of
the synesthesias, you know,
seeing sounds and hearing colors
and that as the trivial example,
but rule breaking within the mind.
But then I've also heard that
perhaps it's lack of gating
of sensory input.
So normally if I'm looking at something,
I'm not thinking about the
sensation in my right toe
unless it's relevant.
But if I'm thinking about the
sensation in my right toe,
I'm generally not thinking
about the truck around the corner.
So we have these attentional spotlights,
but that somehow it creates
a more, it adds spotlights.
- Yeah, degates the thalamus.
- Degates the thalamus, right,
through the particular thalamic structure.
So what is the evidence
that any of that is true?
And are there other phenomena?
Is there involvement of
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
that we are aware of?
And what I'm really headed
here in a few minutes is,
you know, is there a place
for combining directed
stimulation of the brain
with psychedelics so that the effects
of serotonin could be
primarily within the structures
that you know from your work
to be relevant to depression.
So, but to simplify it first,
what's going on when one takes psilocybin
and why is it interesting
in light of depression?
- Yeah, definitely.
So David Nutt and Robin
Carhart-Harris' work
around neuroimaging
psychedelics are kind of
some of the first folks to do that work.
And to their great surprise,
they thought there was going
to be an increase in activity
on psychedelics and what they
found is the opposite, right?
There's kind of an overall decrease
in the level of activity in
the brain with psychedelics,
but they've also looked at connectivity
and there's this kind of
small world, you know,
large world connectivity
that you think about.
And so, you know, small world meaning
there's kind of a much
more kind of focused
kind of cortical function
or, you know, sub-cortical
function or whatever it is.
And what you see is a difference
in that level of engagement
of brain regions,
the connectivity, kind
of global connectivity,
to your point, kind of increases.
And so, you know, it's
interesting, you know,
I think to kind of have a
conversion theory on this.
It's still, you know, to be determined.
There's still a lot of work I
think that needs to be done.
But it's certainly suggestive
that there's pretty profound
changes in brain activity
and brain connectivity after.
And what we've found to
be really interesting is
that the anti-depressant
effects of psilocybin have
a particular connectivity change
that we also see with our
TMS approaches, right?
And it's this connectivity
between the subgenual anterior cingulate
and the default mode network.
And so when we do
this effective Stanford
neuromodulation therapy stimulation,
we see a down regulation, the
connectivity between them,
negatively balanced mood state
in the case of depressed individuals
and the self-representation of the brain.
And you see that same
connectivity change occur
post-psilocybin, you know,
suggesting there's a convergent mechanism
and it makes sense, right?
You've kind of got
an overconnected,
negatively balanced system,
conflict system that's kind of attached
onto the self representation
and people feel stuck, right?
And then when you do whatever
you do that's effective,
it unpairs those two systems.
- I want to ask you about this
phenomenon I've heard about
during psilocybin journeys.
I heard about this from
Dr. Matthew Johnson,
who's running a lot of the
clinical trials at Johns Hopkins
and has been a guest on this podcast.
He said that there's something
seems to be important
about the patient who's depressed
or who's under the influence of psilocybin
or the patient who's
trying to get over smoking
or an eating disorder
who's taking psilocybin
and is in the clinic.
That there's something important
to this notion of letting go,
that people will feel as if their thoughts
and their feelings
and maybe even their body
aren't under their control,
and that the clinicians' job
under those circumstances is
of course to make sure that
they're physically safe
so they don't jump out a window or try...
Actually give an example of
a patient who thought that,
I think it was a she,
could move into the painting in the wall,
and obviously that wasn't
true in the real world,
although it was true in her mind.
So they prevented her from doing that.
But that letting go,
that somehow untethering
from the autonomic arousal
that's occurring is important.
Which brings us back to this
idea or me back to this idea
of like a seesaw where
you're sort of letting go
of the hinge and just sort of,
your heart rate's going up,
like just go with it and trust, you know?
Your heart rate's going down,
just go with it and trust.
You're thinking about
something very powerful
and depressing related to your childhood,
you're just supposed to
go there without fear.
You're thinking about what's possible
in terms of what could happen.
So anyway, you get the picture.
Can we think of that
as just the willingness to do
a million different variations
on the emotional Stroop task?
You know, you'll entertain
the full array of rules
within your head and consider them.
Or is there something more to it?
You know, and again,
we're in the outer margins
of understanding here,
but what are your thoughts
on this notion of letting go
as such a key variable
for relief from depression
during the psychedelic journey?
- Yeah, so I'll talk a little bit
about something called exposure
and response prevention therapy,
that's a typical kind of gold
standard treatment for OCD,
and I'll help this a
little bit conceptually.
And so what that really is,
it's a letting go therapy.
And so, you know, exposure
response prevention,
the idea is that you have
to expose the individual
to something that, you know,
something that triggers an obsession
that they then want to do
whatever the compulsion is, right?
And so I'll give you, you know,
my first exposure and
response prevention patient
when I was a resident,
he was very concerned about
leaving the lights on his car.
And so what we did is we went out
and we turned the lights on in
his car and locked his door.
So his lights were on,
and he was super worried, this
is going to kill his battery.
And we went and we spent an
hour talking about things,
and we went back out to his
car and his battery was fine,
and his lights were on.
And he cranked the car and we
did it maybe one other time,
and then all of a sudden
that was gone, right?
And that's the idea is that, you know,
you're essentially exposing.
And you want to do it at levels
that are, from an anxiety
standpoint, tolerable,
but exposing the person to something
and then letting them see
that that exposure ends
up being fine, right?
It ends up not causing the thing
that they end up being worried about.
And so, you know, in some sense,
being in the psychedelic state,
and we are all taught at a level
to retain some level of control.
You know, people have
more or less of that,
but we're all effectively
retaining some level of control.
We all wake up in the
morning and put clothes on
to go into society.
We all try to say, you know,
most people try to say the right things.
They don't try to do things
that are outside of cultural norms
when they're in conversation.
And so we're constantly
at some level controlling
the situation that we're in.
And so it's, you know, it's not,
it makes a lot of sense
that in that state,
part of the therapeutic effect
that may be linked to the
neural circuitry is this idea
of letting go and essentially
letting the system, you know,
the network configuration
maybe, whatever it is,
assume a state
that you've essentially been
fighting the whole time.
The same way that my OCD
patient was fighting this need
to click the off button on
the lights of his car 50 times
before he would go and do
whatever he needed to do.
And in some level, letting go there,
meaning letting us just turn the lights on
and him not do anything,
or letting go meaning in
the psychedelic state,
you're just letting go
of whatever it is you're holding onto,
negatively balanced
thoughts about yourself
in the setting of having depression
or, you know, re-experiencing
a trauma memory
and allowing that to just happen
and seeing it again
through a different light.
You know, it feels the same
in the sense that that's
allowing for whatever's going on
with these psychedelic states
to do whatever they do.
- It's fascinating.
You said it's exposure response therapy is
the traditional name?
- [Nolan] Exposure response
prevention therapy.
- Prevention therapy.
Done outside of the psychedelic journey.
- It's done outside the
psychedelic journey.
But that idea of letting go
is present in both of those.
You know, psychotherapy
kind of straight up,
totally sober, non psychedelic,
non anything psycho manualized,
that psychotherapy that we
know works really well for OCD.
And then, you know, in
that psychedelic state,
and so people have done
studies with psilocybin,
and now there's some studies
with MDMA trying to look
at treating OCD, you know,
with this same sort of
idea of letting go, right?
And how do you have an OCD
patient kind of let go?
Maybe even letting go of not
washing their hands anymore,
you know, kind of accepting the idea
they're not going to
get germs in their hands
or whatever it is, you know?
And so it's kind of part and parcel,
that same sort of thinking.
- When I was in college,
I developed a compulsive superstition.
I'm not afraid to admit this.
I somehow developed a
knock on wood superstition.
And I was actually kind of ashamed of it
because it rationally made no sense.
I don't consider myself
a superstitious person,
never was a superstitious kid.
You know, I'd step on the sidewalk cracks,
I'd walk under ladders, you know,
I'd probably even try
to walk under a ladder,
even though I don't suggest it.
But somehow I picked this thing up
and I used to sneak it at times.
I told my girlfriend at
the time that I had it
in hopes that that would
prevent me from doing it.
And it's tricky.
Sometimes it actually comes
back where I think, gosh,
I didn't say, you know, knock on wood,
I didn't knock on wood, I hope
that doesn't actually happen.
And it's quote unquote crazy, right?
But crazy in the sense that
it makes no sense rationally
why the events would be linked.
And yet I think a lot of
people out there do have
internal superstitions.
Maybe by talking about
it now, it'll go away.
Clearly I just need to challenge it.
You know, anyway, I mention
it because I consider myself,
you know, generally rational person,
but it's interesting how these
motor patterns get activated
and this notion of letting go,
because I don't actually
know what consequence I fear.
And the fear, as I was
hearing the example you gave,
you know, the fear of the
car battery running down,
I was about to say,
"Well, what if the battery
actually did run out?"
Then the therapy would be undermined.
And yet that could also
be interesting too,
because it's not that big of a deal.
You jump the car.
But in my case,
I need to think about
what the ultimate fear is.
- Yeah, and you know, I
think a lot of people,
so it's interesting if you
look at, say, the OCD scale
or the depression scale or whatever,
we don't define normal as zero.
We define normal as
some number range above.
So zero to, in the case
of the Montgomery-Asberg
Depression Rating Scale,
one of the depression
scales we use, 10, right?
That's the normal range.
And so people could have some sadness
and still be considered normal.
In the case of the OCD scale,
it's about the same 10, right?
Where we say it's kind of
starts to be, you know,
mildly abnormal or something.
And I'd always tell the medical students,
"Look, my friends that
are surf instructors,
they're more like a zero on the Y bar.
People that are professionals,
you know, they're non-zero,
but it's still within the normal range."
And especially, you know,
in the case that you're talking about,
it doesn't sound like it got in your way.
It doesn't sound, I mean,
you're obviously highly
successful tenured professor
at Stanford and do all the
great things that you do.
And so it's very much kind
of within the normal range,
and I think totally assumed
that a lot of people have
these sorts of things.
And as long, I think something
as a psychiatric diagnosis
when it severely impairs
your ability to function
and that's when we kind
of cross that threshold.
But, you know, I think
that a lot of people,
and it's great that
you're bringing this up.
I mean, it's very anti-stigmatizing
that you're bringing up, right?
Because I think a lot of
people hold that stuff in
and they don't want to talk
about it because they're worried
that somebody else may think something.
But the reality is, as a psychiatrist,
I talk to a lot of patients,
a lot of people that are,
you know, family members,
you know, folks that are just going
through a death in the
family, whatever it is.
And what you figure out is like,
everybody's got a little
something here and there.
Everybody has the knock in
some way, if that makes sense.
And it's just, and we're all
just kind of more predisposed
not to talk about it.
But I think it's
important to talk about it
because I think that when we
start all talking about it,
then we realize that we're
all kind of in this together
in a way.
And then some folks that
have to knock 100 times,
we call that OCD, you know,
and they're worried about germs
and all these other things.
We call that OCD.
And then in that circumstance, you know,
they need treatment, right?
But it is really on,
just like blood sugar,
just like blood pressure,
it's on a range, you know,
and it's not just these
discreet diagnoses.
You have them or you don't.
- It's good to know.
I actually feel some
relief just hearing this,
because I am slightly...
I wouldn't say ashamed as
sort of embarrassed by it,
but I offer it as a, you know,
it is what it is, as they say.
And it certainly doesn't
seem to hinder my life much,
knock on wood.
- [Nolan] [laughs] Nice.
- So if we could talk
a bit about ibogaine.
I don't know much about ibogaine,
although anytime I hear
the, you know, A-I-N-E,
you know, lidocaine, ibogaine,
I think of an anesthetic.
And going to the dentist,
which is an unpleasant
experience for me, generally.
What is ibogaine?
Does this have anything to
do with the so-called toad?
You know, people talk about
smoking frog skin, toad skin.
What is it used for clinically?
Is it legal in the US as a clinical tool?
Who's using it and for what purposes?
If you could educate me on ibogaine,
I truly know nothing about it,
except I think I know how
to spell it correctly.
- Yeah, that's fair, yeah.
So ibogaine is one of the alkaloids
that you can extract from
a iboga tree root bark
that's typically growing in
the country of Gabon, Africa.
So Gabon is one of the
West African countries,
kind of middle of Africa
and on the west coast.
And Gabon has a group of folks, you know,
called the Bwiti.
It's a religious kind of sacramental group
that sacramentally uses iboga root bark
as part of the sacrament.
And they've been using iboga
root bark for a very long time.
And it's, you know, part of the tradition.
There's a whole set of
kind of ceremony around it.
If you're interested in this,
there's a book called
"Breaking Open the Head"
by Daniel Pinchbeck that goes through
and talks about this whole process.
But essentially the Gabonese
have been using this
for a long time and it's a kind
of an atypical psychedelic.
It's not a psychedelic that
we normally think about
with psilocybin and LSD
where there are visual
perceptual changes, right?
So if you take psilocybin or LSD,
what you experience is you experience
these kind of visual
perceptual differences
in the external world, right?
And on enough LSD or psilocybin,
an individual can actually
perceive something visually
in the external world that isn't there,
as we talked about earlier.
Ibogaine doesn't do that.
Ibogaine does something different.
It's kind of like, have you
ever seen "Minority Report,"
you know, the movie with Tom Cruise,
I think 15 or 20 years ago or something?
So it dates us a little bit,
but it was this movie where
he would be able to go
and see these kind of pre crimes.
And he had this big screen
where he could look at scenes
from time and like kind of go
through that scene and see it.
And so what individuals
taking ibogaine will say is
that open eyes, they don't see anything,
but closed eyes, they'll go back through
and re-experience earlier life memories
and they will be able to experience it
from a place of empathy,
not only for themselves,
but from others, and
kind of detached empathy
and being able to see this
as almost a third party,
even though they were there.
But they're able to see it,
you know, as a third party.
So Claudia Naranjo, a
psychiatrist from Argentina,
described this for a lot
of books that he wrote,
in I think the '80s and '90s around this.
And so, you know, ibogaine's
been around for a long time.
Howard Lotsof,
American guy that brought
it over from Africa.
He was a polysubstance user,
used every drug that he
could get his hands on,
took ibogaine,
and including a lot of other
psychedelics, by the way,
took ibogaine
and then never did another
drug again, supposedly
because he had such a
profound ibogaine experience.
Ibogaine is in no way a
recreational substance.
It's not a recreational substance
if you want it to be a
recreational substance,
because you're essentially having this,
what they call life review.
They also call it 10 years
of psychotherapy in a night.
So these are the terminology
that people talk about the issue.
- How long does it last?
Is it truly one night?
- It's usually, you know, it can go,
depending upon if you
get re-dosed or anything,
go sometimes, depending upon
how fast you metabolize it,
sometimes 24, sometimes 36 hours.
Sometimes it can be shorter,
but it is a long time.
It's a very long time.
So it's definitely the longest
acting psychedelic substance
I know of.
And so people, you will take this,
and they'll have this
reevaluation of a given memory.
And then as we were talking about earlier,
reconsolidate that memory again,
and then it seems to
have, you know, an effect
of that reconsolidation process.
And so, you know, about
five, four, five years ago,
I was tapped by Robert Malenka,
one of the senior
neuroscientists we both know
in the university.
And he says, "Well,
there's an unnamed donor
that's very interested
in funding a scientific,
kind of open label study
of these Navy SEALs
that have been going down to Mexico
and taking ibogaine and also 5-MeO-DMT,"
which I'll talk about in
a second, to treat PTSD.
You know, they claim to
have traumatic brain injury,
depression, you know, that
whole constellation of symptoms.
You know, and as it was described to me
by various people that had done this,
by their spouses and
and whatnot, you know,
John, we'll just say John,
John couldn't screw a light bulb
into a light fixture, right?
They were just so debilitated
they couldn't do simple tasks,
what we call activities of daily living.
And they were coming back
and having these really
dramatic improvements
in all aspects of life.
And so, you know,
we have over the last
couple of years been able
to do this first in human,
kind of full neurobiological clinical
neurocognitive evaluation
of what ibogaine is doing.
In this case, in special operations,
special forces individuals,
former Navy SEALs,
former Army Rangers, that
kind of crew of folks,
and look at the pre-post changes
that their experience to be able
to totally quantitate all of that.
And so we've been able to
capture all the clinical scales,
you know, depression scales, PTSD scales,
all that standard stuff,
neurocognitive batteries.
So how does your executive
function work specifically?
How does your verbal memory, all of that?
And then neuroimaging and EEG.
So this will be the first human
study of ibogaine for those.
And the reason why is because
ibogaine is kind of the...
Both seemingly the most potent
and most seemingly, to me at least,
most powerful psychedelic,
but the one that has the most risk too,
because it has a cardiac effect.
It seems to be that you
can screen people out
that have risk off of
their electrocardiogram
and reduce the risk quite a bit.
And that's what we all did.
But that's why people haven't
really studied it as much.
And it isn't as, in addition,
nobody goes to a rave on ibogaine.
There's no recreation at all with this.
- It's not fun.
- It's, people say that it's relieving,
but it's hard work, right?
Because yeah, you're reexamining things.
And you know, and so then
we see these folks after,
and I'll tell you, you know,
we haven't fully analyzed the data yet,
but I'll tell you that, you know,
from what my folks are telling
me, it's pretty dramatic.
You know, people come back and
they're doing a lot better.
They're doing a lot better.
And nobody, I'll knock on wood,
nobody's had any sort
of cardiac issue at all
in the cohort that we've studied
and they look a lot better and
they feel a lot better too.
And they describe these experiences
of being able to go back
through and, you know,
soldiers experienced something
called moral injury, right?
Where maybe they accidentally
blew something up
and had a kid in it or
something like that.
You know, if they're in Afghanistan, Iraq,
maybe, you know, a child died on accident
or maybe a civilian died
or whatever it was, right?
And they suffer these moral
injuries as part of the job.
And it's almost one of the
kind of vocational risks.
They come back and say that
they've forgiven themselves,
you know, which is huge, right?
And part of that is being
able to see themselves
in a different light and
having empathy finally
for themselves and being able
to kind of have that
experience of forgiving.
And so, very cool.
The study, you know,
what was happening was
they were taking ibogaine
and then taking something
called 5-MeO-DMT.
People call it the Toad,
it's the Sonoran River Toad.
I think it's like you
can find these in Mexico,
find 'em in Arizona.
In the back of the toad produces
something called 5-MeO-DMT,
which is a flavor of DMT
that produces a particular
psychedelic effect
also used as a sacrament.
- Is it dimethyltryptamine?
- It is a 5-MeO dimethyltryptamine.
So it's a kind of a dimethyltryptamine
with a kind of addition to it.
The deal there is that it lasts
longer than traditional DMT.
You know, it's like 20
minutes to five, three,
or whatever kind of thing.
And so these guys were taking ibogaine
and then they would take
the 5-MeO-DMT after.
We had to kind of divorce those two things
to be able to do the study
and just understand what
the ibogaine was doing.
And they'd go back down a month later
and they'll do the 5-MeO-DMT.
- So two completely separate sessions.
- [Nolan] Two completely
separate sessions.
- And then one quick
question about ibogaine
before a bit more on 5-MeO-DMT.
Is the ibogaine journey guided,
or the person just closes their eyes
and they just start falling
into the back catalog of memories?
- They have a bunch of
preparatory sessions,
and then they have a
bunch of sessions after
that they're able to
kind of rehash things.
During, there's a sitter that sits there
and kind of sits with
them and helps them out,
but it's not, it's pretty, the
phenomenon of the drug seems
to drive a lot of this, right?
And so a lot of it ends up being
what we call supportive psychotherapy.
You're just kind of being there
and, you know, maybe you're
holding the person's hand,
maybe you're just saying "I'm here,"
or maybe whatever it is,
but you're making sure
they know you're around.
But there's not really
an interaction per se.
And then the whole kind
of goal there is just
to get folks to kind go back through
and reexamine these memories
and ultimately look like
they reconsolidate them.
And you know, it's very interesting.
I mean, there's this kind
of, as you said earlier,
Timothy Leary kind of
sociocultural construct
that ends up being
overlaid over psychedelics.
And what I think is
that if you rid yourself
of all of those preconceived notions
of what it is and isn't,
and the counterculture movement,
all that stuff that neither
of us were ever involved in,
neither of us are ever
partake in, you know,
as kind of straight scientists
looking at this, right?
If you can kind of rid yourself
of all those sociocultural constructions
and then reexamine this,
if we just discovered these today,
we would say that these sorts of drugs are
a huge breakthrough in psychiatry
because they allow for us to do a lot
of the sorts of things we've
been thinking about with SSRIs,
with psychotherapy, but
kind of combined, right?
Psychotherapy plus drugs
in a substance that kind of allows you
to reexamine these things.
And so it's interesting.
There's a lot to do to try
to figure out if that's true,
you know?
And I can say that as it stands right now,
we don't know if that
statement is true, right?
There's a lot more work
that needs to happen
for that statement to
be proven to be true.
But the hypothesis is, if it is true,
then it's very likely
that this will be seen
as a breakthrough because it allows you
to do these sorts of
things that you can't do
with normal waking consciousness.
But also why we have to
really think about this.
And, you know, these drugs
can't be recreational drugs.
They really shouldn't be
recreational drugs, right?
They're really too powerful to be used
in the context of recreation
because they can put
you into these states.
And this generation of
psychedelic researchers are
really clear about that.
You know, I think the '60s
folks were not clear about that,
and they felt like there
was this whole kind
of cultural thing that was going on there.
But I think this cohort of
individuals really understands
that in order to really make this happen,
we have to understand
that if you need a
prescription for an SSRI,
which doesn't change your
consciousness a whole lot,
and we're very worried about that,
and the doctor has to evaluate
you for that every week,
that the idea that some of these
substances would go outside
of very strict medical supervision is
kind of preposterous actually.
It's kind of a dumb moment, I think,
for all of medicine to say,
look, if we're going to do this right,
we've got to do it such a
way that's so protected,
that's so safe, that we
make sure people know
these things are not recreational
and they're really for the pure purposes
of really powerfully changing
cognition for a while
and letting people have these
what seem to be, you know,
relatively therapeutic states.
- I think it's great that
you're doing this study.
And along the lines of the
sort of the early iterations
of psychedelics and the
counterculture of the '60s and '70s,
some of which took place,
like "One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest"
I think is actually based
on the Menlo Park VA,
which is in our neighborhood of Stanford.
And things are quite a bit different now.
I know you and I have spent
some time with the operators
and former operators at an event,
and last Veterans Day, in fact,
the so-called Veteran Solutions group
that's pioneering a lot of
these psychedelic treatments
for former special operators
and current special operators.
And what's interesting to me about that is
in contrast to the counterculture movement
of the '60s and '70s, that
room was filled with people
that are very much of a
structure, the military.
Right?
So it's no longer considered
left wing, right wing,
anti-military, pro-military.
Here this isn't just
about one group of people
who's exploring
psychedelics as a treatment
for trauma and PTSD and other things.
And of course you also have other domains
of society looking at this.
And in fact, there were, but
it was really interesting
because there were both far
left and far right politicians
at that event up on stage together,
talking about, in kind of
lighter terms, heart medicine,
but also talking about
neurobiology and talking.
It was just fascinating
from the perspective
of somebody who's trying
to learn about this stuff,
that psychedelic therapies no longer sit
within the anti-establishment realm.
It's independent of all that,
certainly when people in
the military are adopting it
as a potential treatment.
Again, still under exploration,
but also under exploration
at universities like Stanford
and Johns Hopkins and UCSF
and University College London
and on and on.
Along the lines of tree
barks and toad skins,
tell me about ayahuasca.
And as a plant, you know, it's intriguing.
And is it pro-serotonergic
drug like psilocybin?
And is it useful for the
same sorts of conditions
that we've talked about thus far?
And if you could perhaps
tell me a little bit also
about the Brazilian prisoner study.
- Yeah, yeah.
Definitely.
Ayahuasca is another psychedelic.
It's used as a sacrament
in Brazil and in Peru
and Ecuador, in Columbia.
So a lot of the South American countries.
And what they do is they
combine two plants together,
where one plant of the
two plant combination
would effectively do nothing,
but the two plant combination
together is capable
of producing this very
profound psychedelic effect.
And what's really kind of
curious is that there are,
as I understand it,
10 to 20,000 plant species in the Amazon.
And somehow, somebody-
- Someone tried 'em all.
- Combined these two plants together
in certain proportionality
and cooked this for five, 10 hours
to the point where you cook
out the dimethyltryptamine
out of one of the plants
and cook out the reversible
monoamine oxidase inhibitor
out of the other plant in such a way
that the reversible monoamine
oxidase inhibitor prevents
the GI breakdown of the dimethyltryptamine
in such a way that it's then allowed
to cross the blood-brain
barrier and get into the brain.
And if you didn't add
the reversible monoamine
oxidase inhibitor plant derived
into this combination,
then it would never cross the brain.
If you put people on a standard,
psychiatry prescribed
monoamine oxidase inhibitor
that wasn't reversible,
you'd throw them into
serotonin syndrome, right?
So this kind of like sweet spot
that somehow ayahuasca
practitioners have found
of being able to get DMT into
the brain from an oral source
with this combination of a
monoamine oxidase inhibitor
is curious.
And so that substance has been explored
as an antidepressant agent,
and some studies have looked at that.
It also seems to be very safe.
There's a psychiatrist down at UCLA Harbor
who's done a lot of work with this,
where he's looked at children even
that have been exposed to kind
of small doses of ayahuasca
as kind of a sacrament
within Amazonian tribes
and found no neurocognitive effects,
no neurocognitive effects in adults.
And so it appears to be safe.
It's kind of part and brought
into various religions,
including kind of merged with
Catholicism in South America,
which is kind of very interesting.
And so, you know, in some
sects of Catholicism in Brazil,
it's used as a sacrament
during religious ceremonies.
And so it became interesting
to Brazilian researchers
as to whether or not they
could affect recidivism rates
for prisoners in Brazilian prisons, right?
So they gave half of
the prisoners, you know,
some sort of inert substance
and half of the prisoners
an ayahuasca session.
And the recidivism rate or
the return to prison rate
in the ayahuasca exposed individuals was
statistically significantly
lower than the recidivism rate
in the control group,
suggesting that, you know,
whatever is going on there
seems to have an effect
on whatever drives criminal behavior,
whatever criminal behavior
that happened to be.
And I don't have the details
on the exact nature of the crime.
You know, I am also in no way saying
that we should just be giving psychedelics
to folks in prison and all of that.
I think that that is a
very edgy thing to do
and probably not something
that anybody should try,
but it does kind of bring
up this curious question
of what is it about that
that would drive people
to change those behaviors
and why do people make
those behavioral decisions?
And a lot of times
if you look at prisons
in the United States,
you know, people say this,
what's the biggest mental health facility
in the United States?
It's a prison.
- Yeah, there's a lot to
unpack there for sure.
You know, the homeless
issue, the prison issue.
It does lead to something
that I heard recently,
which is related to all
this, which is cannabis.
You know, we hear a lot
nowadays about people will say,
well, it's safer than alcohol.
And we did an episode on alcohol that,
at least by my read of the literature,
indeed alcohol does seem to be quite bad
for our health beyond...
I think it's pretty clear
that not drinking is better
for your health than drinking at all.
And here, I'm not trying
to tell people what to do,
but those are what the data say.
And forget the studies on red wine.
You'd have to drink so much red wine
to get enough resveratrol.
It's not even clear resveratrol
does anything useful anyway,
et cetera, et cetera.
Nonetheless, cannabis is now available
in a lot of very high potency forms.
People are vaping cannabis,
people are smoking cannabis.
I certainly am not saying
that cannabis is bad
for people necessarily,
although I think children,
I would hope
that their brain development
would be completed first,
you know, get to age 25.
I know that sounds late
for a lot of people,
but the THC obviously taps
into some endogenous systems
and the cannabinoid
systems and is powerful.
And I've seen this report
that was in Lancet Psychiatry
this last year that said that
early use of potent cannabis,
meaning age 14 to 20 or so,
can potentially lead to an exacerbation
of psychosis later in life.
And I actually put this
out on social media
and it sort of exploded.
I didn't expect it to.
And people were saying,
well, that's not causal.
And obviously it's not causal
because people say, well,
maybe people with psychotic tendencies
are seeking out cannabis.
Although that's sort of a weak argument
in the sense that there's
at least a 4X increase
in these psychotic episodes
for people later in life.
But what are your thoughts about cannabis?
Because I do want to acknowledge
that it does have medical
benefits for certain things,
pain, chemotherapy.
So by no means trying to knock on cannabis
and its appropriate medicinal use.
But what should we think about cannabis
in terms of this finding
that it can exacerbate a
psychosis in certain individuals?
- Yeah, so I think, you know,
there's a couple of things, right?
So cannabis is multiple
cannibinoids, right?
- Right, THC, CBD, CBN,
sativas, and, you know, indicas,
it gets, yeah, there's
a lot there to unpack.
- Yeah, there's a lot.
But there are two main kind
of chemicals you think about
and kind of how things are
essentially bred, right?
And so, you know,
there's a lot of cannabis
that's really bred to be
very high, very potent THC.
And there's cannabis where
the THC's bred completely out.
So there's stories, you
know, from Colorado, right?
This strain of cannabis that's THC free,
there's no THC at all, and it's all CBD,
and it's called Charlotte's Web.
And a bunch of kids' parents, one kid,
and then kind of a string
of parents after that moved
to Colorado when cannabis was legalized,
because CBD is antiepileptic,
so CBD is also antipsychotic.
And so there have been a number of studies
that if you give CBD at high doses,
it's antipsychotic in established
schizophrenic patients.
The issue is
that we've bred CBD out of
marijuana selectively over time.
We've gotten very good
at figuring out how to do that, right?
Conversely, THC is pro psychotic
and pro epileptic, right?
And so when you talk about
does cannabis cause psychosis
or does cannabis treat psychosis,
it appears to be more related
to the proportions of CBD to THC
than it does to the kind
of idea of cannabis.
So for me,
and I have no stock in
this or anything like that,
but there's a company
called GW Pharmaceuticals,
and I haven't looked into them in a while,
but they have a lot of clinical trials
for something called Dravet Syndrome,
which is a seizure disorder
where kids seize a whole lot,
Lennox-Gastaut syndrome,
which is a seizure disorder,
kids are seizing 300 times a day.
Both of these are like
kids are seizing so much,
they're basically in a seizure
or in the postictal phase constantly.
And they've failed everything.
They've failed barbiturates,
they've failed bromides,
which we just don't use
anymore except in these cases
because of the side effects.
And they'll give kids CBD.
And I think CBD is a pretty safe drug
compared to bromide, right?
And so this idea that CBD
in a kid is actually safe,
it's a cannabinoid, but it's
CBD and it's safe, right?
And so that to me is totally fine.
Also giving CBD as an adjunctive treatment
for schizophrenia.
There have been some positive trials
and negative trials in that,
but there seems to be no
negative side effects.
It seems to reduce some of
the metabolic syndrome issues
in folks with schizophrenia
who are having side effects
from the primary antipsychotic.
The converse is, there's
clearly cases where people
that are taking very high
doses of THC become psychotic,
they get put into the
psychiatric unit, nothing happens
other than they kind of get
the THC out of their system,
and then they resolve
their psychosis, right?
And so that, and you know,
a handful of people who have had seizures
related to high doses of THC and syncope
and all sorts of things.
And so this idea that THC,
high doses of THC can be pro psychotic,
is also not taking a shot at people
that think that cannabis
overall is a good thing.
It's just, it just is what it is.
And the kind of pure, I
think if you zoom back
and you say you're a true naturalist,
you're thinking about natural
medicines in the world,
you should think, well,
probably marijuana was
balanced THC CBD at some point,
and then we humans messed with it, right?
And that most likely, that was
probably okay at some level,
and then we pushed it one way or another.
And what I mean by okay
is in a 45 year old,
it's okay, kind of thing.
Now, what I think is
going on with the kids,
with the teenagers,
is you've got prefrontal
maturation, right?
And then you're exposing them
to a whole lot of high THC load.
And while it's unclear
if it's cause or effect,
it's certainly in the picture.
And if I were a parent,
I wouldn't want my 16 year
old smoking marijuana.
If I were a parent and my 30
year old, otherwise healthy,
totally fine, you know, whatever,
banker, lawyer kid decided
to try marijuana for the first time,
I wouldn't scold them about it, right?
So I think it's this kind
of a different thing, right?
I would never want my up to 25 year old,
just like you're saying,
before prefrontal maturation,
I would never want my
kid to be exposed at all.
But it looks like, except
in susceptible individuals
that are susceptible to
drug-induced psychosis,
it looks like, you know,
it's a relatively safe thing
past prefrontal maturation.
You know, again, I'm not going
to comment of cause and effect,
but I would say that, you
know, if you're a parent,
it doesn't make much sense, right?
You never know what's ultimately
going to hurt your kid.
I mean, we were talking
about this earlier,
my wife's pregnant now.
She kind of avoids everything, right?
Rightfully so, right?
This idea that we just,
we want to be careful
when our children's brains are developing.
And I think that's really
what you were saying
and I think actually important.
The bigger question that you asked,
which is relative risks of
drugs, is an interesting one.
So David Nutt published in, I
think it was in "The Lancet,"
I'll have to look it up,
but I think in "The Lancet,"
an article about relative drug risks
for the person and for society.
And this was like,
he was on the UK's like
British Drug Policy Group,
where essentially what he showed was
if you look at societal
risk plus personal risk,
and you combine those two,
you know what drug is the most
dangerous drug in the world?
- I'm going to guess it's alcohol.
- It's alcohol,
right behind heroin and
cocaine and da da da da da,
and somewhere in the middle is marijuana.
And right on the tail end,
on the exact other end
of this, psilocybin.
- Is caffeine, usually
doesn't make the list.
- It may have been on the list.
If it was, it was probably
pretty close to psilocybin,
but somewhere in the middle was ketamine,
somewhere in the middle was amphetamine,
somewhere in the, you know,
a little closer to psilocybin,
I think was MDMA, you know.
But it's this combined
personal kind of world risk
of these things.
And so alcohol makes it,
because there's a huge
amount of personal risk
and there's a huge amount
of societal risk, right?
Drunk drivers kill X amount
of people in the world.
- Fight, sexual assault, all that.
- All that, yeah.
And then all the cancer
and all that stuff.
And so it beats out cocaine,
it beats out heroin,
it beats out all of these things.
And yet, we don't, as a
culture, for whatever reason,
we don't as a culture see it as a drug.
And that's the part that
really baffles me, you know?
- I mean, they serve it.
I mean, this is no knock
on Stanford at all.
Of course, I wouldn't do that.
This is at every institution I've been to,
they serve alcohol at the
graduate student events.
- [Nolan] That's right.
- You know, they serve alcohol.
They do a happy hour.
I've never been a drinker.
I can take it or leave it.
- [Nolan] Yeah, same.
- And I realize that some people,
they really enjoy alcohol.
You know, my former partner, I mean,
she just was in that 10% or so of people
who have a glass of wine
and just feel great.
And the second one, feel great.
I just want to take a nap
after I have a bit of alcohol,
so it never does much for me.
I always feel poisoned.
I feel lucky in that sense.
But it's unbelievable
that it is so prevalent
and it's just, it's
baked into the medical,
even medical institutions,
they'll pop a bottle of champagne
to celebrate the opening of a hospital.
- [Nolan] That's right, that's right.
- You know, that's pretty crazy.
- Yeah, no, you're absolutely right.
You know, I think what's going to happen,
but this is me, you know,
looking at the crystal ball a little bit,
but I think what's going to happen is
what happened with doctors and smoking.
So if you look at the
'50s and '60s, right?
There are all these pictures
of doctors smoking cigarettes,
you know, with patients or, you know,
psychiatrists doing psychotherapy
and smoking a cigarette
with the patient sitting on the couch,
you know, surgeons smoking a
cigarette in between cases,
there are all these
pictures of that, right?
And now all of a sudden,
smoking's totally banned.
I think it's totally banned
from most of Stanford campus.
My suspicion is, as
you're suggesting, right?
You know, this is everywhere
and it's all kind of ubiquitous.
At some critical point,
some tipping point,
everybody's going to realize
that, just like with smoking,
we've got to rid hospital systems
and universities of alcohol.
And at some point in 50 years,
it's my view that we'll look
it back at these scenarios
that you're talking about
and be like, you know what,
we were foolish about this.
I can't believe that
we gave people alcohol
when they graduated
from whatever, you know?
And I think we'll have
a different take on it,
but it's going to take a longer time.
I think people did a really
good job tying smoking
to lung cancer and it's like
a very simplistic story.
Smoking, lung cancer, you know?
Now, as you know,
alcohol increases the risk of
a lot of different cancers.
Not so clear which one.
I mean, there's like, you
know, the kind of oral,
like the throat, tongue
cancer, that's one of-
- Breast cancer.
- Yeah, breast cancer, you know?
And so it's kind of just,
it's a harder story to tell,
you know?
And I think that's why, and everybody,
you know, and then there's this whole,
it's, you know, my mom says this.
It's like I drank my glass of wine
because my doctor told
me it was heart healthy.
And we were talking
about this, and I try to,
no, no, no, but Dr. So-and-so
said it's heart healthy.
And so it ends up being this thing
where like she's drinking
alcohol because she thinks
that it's good for her heart.
And, you know, and it's hard.
I've had those conversations with her.
It's hard to untie that.
And I think that, yeah,
at some point we're going to
hit some threshold moment.
And it'll be interesting if
we really look at the data
and we really look at
what's safe and not safe
purely from this analysis,
it kind of points to the right direction.
- It's really interesting.
And also say nothing of poor judgment
under the influence of alcohol.
I mean, I would venture
that if we were to remove
alcohol from university campuses,
watch, the students are
going to lobby against me
if I say this.
But if you were to remove
alcohol from campuses,
I mean, just think about
what I suspect would be
the improvement in good decision making.
And that would occur.
Or, you know, I've got stories
from graduate school and...
It was very different,
you know, 10 years ago.
There was a lot more alcohol consumption.
Again, that was never my thing,
but I know people who
make really bad decisions.
In any case, there's a whole
landscape there emerging.
I think you got your finger
right on the pulse of it.
I want to touch on
something slightly different
than what we've been talking about,
but definitely related to depression.
And this, again,
is one of these intriguing
but perplexing things,
which is that sleep deprivation
can improve symptoms
of depression.
And yet I'm personally
very familiar with the fact
that if I don't sleep well for one night
or don't sleep at all, in fact,
I do have an ability to function
pretty well the next day.
I'll do this non-sleep deep rest practice
that I blab a lot about on
the Huberman Lab Podcast,
which for me is tremendously restorative,
but I like a good night's sleep.
I think everybody understands now,
thanks to the great work of Matthew Walker
and others that have really
gotten out into the world
saying, look, the
foundation of mental health,
physical health, and high
performance, if that's your thing,
being a functional human being,
is to try and get enough
quality deep sleep
at least 80% of the nights
of your life, if you can.
That's something to focus on.
Just like good nutrition,
just like exercise and
social connection, et cetera.
So sleep deprivation,
we know, in particular,
I think rapid eye movement
components of sleep deprivation
can improve the symptoms of depression.
And yet being sleep deprived
can also really disregulate
our control of the autonomic system.
I notice on night two or
night three of poor sleep,
if I'm going through a stressful
phase and that's happening,
all of a sudden my heart
rate is chronically elevated,
my thought patterns
become really disrupted.
I can't then exercise, my
decision making is thrown off,
my emotionality is more labile.
The hinge, as we were
referring to it earlier,
feels less in control, under my control.
And maybe I wonder sometimes
if I enter that state
that you refer to earlier,
where the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex is
no longer leading the cingulate,
but the cingulate is now in charge.
The players are in charge of the coach.
Not a good situation.
So I know you've done some
work on sleep deprivation
and light and effects.
Please tell us about that
and please tell us about
this triple therapy.
Is that?
- Yeah, yeah.
So friend of mine, Greg Salem,
another one of the professors at Stanford,
was very interested in sleep.
He did a bunch of training in sleep
before he went to medical school
and got very interested in this
idea that, as you're saying,
if you sleep deprive somebody one night
in just kind of an isolated single night,
at the end of that sleep deprivation,
they will have an antidepressant effect,
but as soon as they fall
asleep, they lose it.
So if it's a depressed individual,
you can get them to be
less depressed acutely.
Soon as they fall asleep, they
wake up eight hours later,
then they come back into the
same level of depression.
And so the idea is that you needed
to do some sort of circadian reset.
And that part of what depression is,
is that it's a dysregulated
circadian system.
And so mentors of mine say,
if you can just get the sleep better,
that's half the battle of
dealing with depression.
'Cause so many people have
insomnia around depression
and have a whole host
of types of insomnia.
Having a hard time falling asleep,
waking up in the middle of the
night, and waking up earlier,
all symptoms of depression.
And so what this does is it
sleep deprives the individual
and then there's a certain calculation
of shifting their phase
and simultaneously exposing
them to bright lights.
So that's the triple, the phase shift,
the sleep deprivation,
and the bright light,
to try to get their circadian rhythm.
Essentially the theory is reintrained.
And so, you know, in the
trials that we've done
and other trials prior to
ours and after, you know,
it looked like there was
a pretty profound antidepressant effect
from this triple therapy
that seemed to be durable,
meaning durability is this term we use
to say that not only can you
get kind of point relief,
but that the relief ends
up, you know, lasting.
What's important to
know about this is like,
you shouldn't do this at home for sure.
You would need to do
this with a professional,
'cause it's complicated,
it's not just one thing.
And sleep deprivation,
while it seems to be
antidepressant, it's pro anxiety.
So if you take a highly anxious
person that's not depressed
and you sleep deprive them,
they get profoundly anxious.
And so that's the other thing
that you have to really realize is
that this is like everything else
that I've talked about today,
all things that you have to
do under medical supervision,
but curious, right?
And I think, you know, the
question that always comes up is
why isn't this used more?
And I think the reason is
that there's not really a
mechanism for, you know,
ultimately in medicine, as sad as it is,
you have to have a code to do a thing.
There has to be a code
associated with a treatment
and it's hard to figure out
how to make a code for this.
And so I think that's part of it.
And so if there's a way,
and somebody's got to kind
of take that baton on that,
but if there's a way to
make a code for this,
you know, I think you could
actually turn it into something
that was more widely utilized.
And, you know, probably dream up ways
of how to integrate AI, passive sensing,
all that stuff to really make that work.
But I think that would be the idea,
that would be the trajectory
I'd see, so, yeah.
- Yeah, having a billable to
insurance code is fundamental.
And a lot of listeners to this podcast,
I think, have a background
in engineering science.
And we will put a link to that manuscript
that talks about the triple therapy,
because here we're talking
about one night sleep deprivation,
some timed light exposure to the eyes,
and then shifting in the
circadian clock being central
to the themes of the
podcast that come up often.
I think for the typical person,
can we say that trying to get
a regular light dark cycle
at sleep rhythm would be beneficial
for overall mood regulation?
- Yeah, I think for the
typical person, you know,
really kind of reregulating your sleep
and trying to get, you
know, a good night's sleep
in which you fall asleep, stay asleep,
wake up at a set time every
morning is going to be
pretty crucial.
You know, in mild depression,
I think that one has a
lot of control over that.
As we were talking about earlier,
I think when you hit some
threshold in depression
where things become
kind of semi-volitional
and it's harder to kind of
will yourself into that.
There are therapies like, you know,
there's a CBT for insomnia, for instance,
where you can do cognitive
behavioral therapy
to help with insomnia.
Sometimes people, and I'm no sleep expert.
Kind of pass this to Greg
to fully talk about this,
but some of what goes on
that people with kind of
milder insomnia experience is
like blue light out of their
computer and things like that,
so you can use like
blue light blockers to,
it tricks your brain, as
you know better than me,
it tricks your brain to think
that it's still light outside.
And so people will still have insomnia
because their brain still
thinks that it's light outside.
And then people will, you know,
the kind of strict CBT for sleep.
You know, therapists will
say there are only two things
that you should do in your bed.
And if you're under a
certain age and whatnot,
it's really one thing that
you should do in your bed,
which is to sleep and be
with your partner, right?
And so those are kind of the two things
that you should do in a bedroom.
And that's really the only things
that you should do in a bedroom
if you're having sleep problems.
You shouldn't watch TV in a bedroom,
you shouldn't eat in a
bedroom, shouldn't hang out.
- Keep the phone out of the bedroom.
- [Nolan] Keep the phone
out of the bedroom, yeah.
- Yeah.
We should get Greg Salem on the podcast.
I'll just mention
for people that want to
regulate their sleep,
we have a sleep toolkit that's available
as a downloadable PDF at hubermanlab.com.
Just go to the menu
and a lot of the things
in that toolkit are based on work
from Stanford Sleep Laboratories,
including Jamie Zeitz and others' lab,
not aimed at depression specifically.
Listen, Nolan, Dr. Williams,
this has been an amazing voyage
through the circuitry
of autonomic control.
This landscape of the
prefrontal cortex is,
I find incredibly fascinating
and I just want to start off
by saying please do come back again
and teach us more about
that and your TMS work.
Before we wrap, however,
I do want to give you the opportunity
to talk about the SAINT study.
- [Nolan] Yeah, definitely.
- Is it SAINT or SAINTS plural?
- Yeah, it's SAINT.
So SAINT, or we're calling it SNT now.
SAINT has, you know...
The intent was not to kind
of connect it to religion,
but we may have accidentally done so.
And so we abbreviated it to SNT
for the subsequent trials,
which was initially
Stanford Accelerated Intelligent
Neuromodulation Therapy,
or now what we're calling
Stanford Neuromodulation Therapy.
But the idea there, which is a cool idea,
is that TMS is a device
that delivers a treatment,
and the treatment is the protocol.
And the protocol is the
stimulation parameter set
in a specific brain region
for a specific condition.
And so what's cool about neuromodulation,
whether it be transcranial
magnetic stimulation
or transcranial direct current stimulation
or deep brain stimulation,
like what Casey Halpern talked
about on another podcast,
is this idea that in all of those cases,
the device itself is a
physical layer conduit
of a stimulation protocol
that's therapeutic
for a given condition
in a given brain region.
And so in the case of depression,
which we know the most about for with TMS,
we've been doing TMS
studies for depression for,
you know, since 1995, right?
And the clearance in 2000, 2008, 2009.
And in that timeframe,
we were able to go from really
knowing very little at all
about how to do something like this
to getting an FDA clearance.
And the way that it went down was
that there were two groups
studying different components
at NIH.
The first group was
studying mood neuroanatomy
on functional imaging.
That was kind of the first generation
of functional imaging
back then, so PET scans,
which are kind of metabolic
scans, and then SPECT scans.
And the idea there was looking
at activity and metabolism
and prefrontal cortex.
And what they found in these
kind of more crude scans is
that just general
hypoactivity, hypometabolism.
The other group right upstairs
at the National Institute
for Neurological Diseases
and Stroke, NINDS, they
were looking at using TMS,
which had been around for 10 years,
and repetitively
stimulating in motor cortex.
And what they found was, gosh,
we can get a readout in thumb
muscle movement amplitude
that's really reproducible across people.
It's like, you know,
universally reproducible.
And if we do certain
stimulation approaches,
they are biologically active
to either increase excitability,
IE the thumb motion,
and a set intensity goes up,
the amount of amplitude goes up,
or inhibitory or depotentiating,
it goes down with other
biological stimulation approaches.
And then a third outcome,
which is important,
that it's inert, it doesn't do either.
So you can have stimulation
approaches that do one,
you know, increase
activity, decrease activity,
or are inert.
And so what they found was, oh,
we can excite certain brain regions.
Then my mentor, Mark George said,
had this kind of aha moment where he said,
"Wow, there's underactivity
in prefrontal cortex
in depression, and we can
increase activity using this thing
that we know we can increase
activity in motor cortex.
We just need to put it
in the left dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex."
And then they combined the two
and started stimulating once a day
in this kind of very abbreviated fashion.
And lo and behold,
some of those depression patients
resolved their depression.
And back then, and still today,
you can go and as a
psychiatric patient stay
at the National Institute of Mental Health
and go through clinical
trials to try to get treated.
And there were patients
who'd been there for months
and they were able to be discharged.
Because their mood was better, yeah.
And so just very crude approach
where they were using ruler
measurements where DLPFC was,
and they were stimulating with devices
that you needed to physically
dunk the coil in an ice bath.
And with that, they still were able to,
the kind of genius of
this, Mark and others,
they would still be able
to create a purely engineered
stimulation approach.
What's cool about that is
that they kind of found two things, right?
They found this one stimulation protocol
that does have some antidepressant effect.
It's limited, it doesn't treat everybody,
it does have some antidepressant effect.
And this bigger concept that
a neuromodulation device is
kind of like a pharmaceutical
company for you, right?
That in a given individual,
a TMS device or whatever
neuromodulation device is able
to generate, you can create
a stimulation approach
that is specific to a given condition
and specific to an individual.
And so the physical layer
is just how you exert that,
similarly to how we make
pharmaceutical drugs
in a pharmaceutical company.
But the actual therapy
itself is what you do,
where you do it.
And so what we learned from, you know,
another 20, 30 years of this is
that you can modify the
stimulation protocol in such a way
where you can create a whole new treatment
and put it through the same TMS device
or, thank god, an evolved version of it
where you don't have
to dunk it in ice baths
and they can actually really handle
much more aggressive
stimulation approaches.
And so in 2005,
a group published in "Neuron"
a paper demonstrating
that if you stimulate with
the hippocampal rhythms
through a TMS coil,
you can excite the brain
with memory rhythms
and it'll last an hour.
So you can change cortical excitability
in the thumb twitch for an hour,
sending three minutes of excitatory
or 40 seconds in the case
of inhibitory stimulation
that mimics hippocampal rhythms.
So much more efficient than
the original TMS approaches.
And so, you know, after
that group tried to do it
in this kind of six week schedule,
and after that, you know, and
while they were doing that,
we decided, gosh, you know,
this problem I talked about
at the beginning of the show
where you have this problem
that we don't have a treatment
for people who are
in these high acuity psychiatric
emergency states, right?
This idea that we are going
to engineer a treatment
where we can reorganize the
stimulation approach in time
to be much more efficient
by utilizing something
called space learning theory.
And so you probably know about
the space learning theory.
So the idea for the viewers is,
it's a simple psychological thing,
but we've also seen it
in hippocampal slice
sort of physiology too, where
if I'm cramming for a test,
what I do is I write out 60 note cards
and I read each one for a minute
until I get to the first
note card and again,
and that's about an hour later, right?
And we just intuitively do this.
We all, you know, automatically do that.
And we intuit that because we
know that what doesn't work is
writing out one note card
and looking at it over and over again.
Nobody ever does that, right?
You know, we've all been in
graduate school, medical school,
and we have these big
stacks of note cards.
That's space learning theory.
It's this idea that you need
to see it about every hour
to an hour and a half and
that optimizes learning.
If you take the same stimulation approach
that I'm talking about,
this data burst stimulation approach,
and you take a hippocampal
slice of a mouse
and you stimulate, you
enlarge some dendritic spines
and you prime some.
And then if you stimulate
right after that,
you don't get any change.
It's called in mass stimulation.
But if you wait about an
hour to an hour and a half,
you get more dendritic spines
enlarged and more primed.
Which, by the way, also
is what ketamine does,
it causes a dendritic spine enlargement.
And so, you know, what we
found was is that the old way
of doing TMS, this idea of
just doing it once a day,
every day, five days a week for six weeks,
didn't utilize the space learning theory.
It's like studying for a month or two,
just a little bit once a day.
Like you remember some of that stuff,
but it's like not as potent as that week
where you're kind of cramming, right?
And what we realized is
that if we could reorganize
the stimulation in time
so that we took the whole six week course,
we actually figured out
a way to do it in a day.
And then what we also figured out is
that people were underdosing TMS
because if you just keep
going after six weeks
out to month three, four, five,
more and more people got better.
So we figured out it's not just one day,
we're going to give five
times the normal dose.
We're going to have 7 1/2
months' worth in five days
using space learning theory.
- So every hour?
- [Nolan] Every hour for 10 hours.
- For five days.
So it's a 50 hour block.
It's 90 minutes of actual stimulation,
but spread out through the day
in the same way of learning.
Which is perfect for an inpatient
psychiatric unit, right?
- [Andrew] Five days is manageable.
- Yeah, you can get stimulation.
Nobody's ever dropped out by the schedule.
You know, folks that want
to do this, want to do it.
So they'll do their nine minutes,
they'll go get breakfast,
they'll do their nine minutes,
they'll go see their
therapist or whatever it is.
And so what we found
with this reorganization
and time of the stimulation dose,
and then the third component is
we do resting state
functional connectivity scans
on everybody.
And we have ways now in
the last five to 10 years
of picking out that specific
subgenual DLPFC subcircuit
that I was talking about
earlier, that cingulate DLPFC,
we can pick that out in every single one.
If you want to come to the lab,
we can find your DLPFC subgenual.
It's even more robust than non-
- Maybe we could stimulate
too, just while we're in there.
- Yeah, if you want to,
we can move around your hypnotizability.
And we can find that spot in each person.
Instead of finding the
same spot on the skull,
we find the same spot on the
brain, and we can stimulate.
And we do that every hour on the hour.
And what we've found is that folks will,
within one to five days, you
know, in more cases than not,
and depending upon if you're
looking at this open label
or in trials, somewhere
between 60 and 90% of the time,
they will go into full on remission
in the sense they're totally
normal from a mood standpoint
at the end of this.
And like I said, with variable durability.
So that's the part we
have to figure out now
about dosing and how to keep people well.
But for some people, you know,
we've had four years of remission,
you know, year of remission.
And it's really that cramming of the test.
It's really that idea that
you're laying in that information
to the exact right spot.
And the signal is a simple
signal, but it's a profound one,
which is turn on, stay
on, remember to stay on.
You know, that idea that you're
sending this memory signal
into the brain and you're
doing it in such a way
that you're telling the system,
you're kind of taking it out
of your own hippocampus' hand
and you're sending the same signal
the hippocampus normally signals out.
Now you're sending that signal
into the prefrontal cortex
and kind of utilizing the
brain's own communication style
to get it to get out of the state.
And what's very cool
about this is that people,
when they kind of exit out of that,
they end up saying they don't
have any side effects from it.
And they feel back to normal.
Like some people, you know,
not everybody, but there's
a subsection of people
that with SSRIs where they'll
say, I kind of feel numb,
or I have GI side effects,
or I can't, you know,
I don't have the sexual
interest that I used to have
and that sort of thing.
You know, not anything against SSRIs,
as I said earlier, life saving, you know,
for a subsection of people,
these things really work.
But with this, what you see is
that people don't talk
about any of that stuff.
And I think it's likely
because you're tapping
into that core circuitry
and you're reversing it and
you're doing it with a magnet
that, because it's a very
profound electromagnet,
it's the same field
strength as an MRI scanner,
it's able to induce a current in the brain
in this focal targeted way
without getting into
the rest of the brain,
without getting into the
rest of the body at all.
And just really kind of
acting only on that circuitry
that's involved.
- Incredible.
Is the SAINT study still ongoing?
And if people are interested
in potentially being patients
or subjects in the study, can
we provide them a portal link?
- Absolutely, yeah.
So we have, now the treatment,
some of my students went over
to a company called Magnus Medical,
and they've been working on this,
they've got an FDA clearance now.
And now folks can get it through trials
over the next couple of years
because it's going to take
some time for that company
to kind of get up and
running and get a device
and get the whole thing set up nationally.
But while that's all going on,
there's still about 1,000
patients that need to be recruited
across a bunch of different
trials all over the country.
We'll take people from
anywhere in the country.
We also have partners in
New York and San Diego
and in soon to be South
Carolina and other places
where we can actually kind of, you know,
my lab can help to kind of
let people know where to go,
based off of where they're at in the US,
and get them access to
being able to be in a trial.
And what we've tried to do is make it
so that even if you get
the, you know, 50 50 chance,
you're going to get the real deal
or you're going to get the non-real deal.
But what we have figured out is a way
to let everyone have access.
If they got the not real deal version,
the kind of sham version
or the fake version,
for the first part of the trial,
there are other trials
where they can have access
to the real version.
So essentially everybody
eventually gets access
to having the real version.
And so that's been a big thing for me is
I want everybody that comes
through one of our trials
to be able to have access.
I think it's important.
While the company's
doing what they're doing
and what the lab's doing,
and kind of nationally what
other partner labs are doing.
- Well, I can assure you, you're
going to get some interest.
- [Nolan] Happy to have it, yeah.
- Thank you.
And listen,
thank you so much for taking
us on this incredible voyage
through the neurocircuitry
underlying certain aspects
of depression,
the coverage of the different
types of depression,
the various therapeutic
compounds, how they work.
We've talked about a lot of things today.
You've shared so much knowledge,
and even as I say that,
I very much want to have you back
to talk about many other things as well
that we didn't have time to cover,
but also just really want to thank you
for the work that you do.
I know we are colleagues,
but you run an enormous
laboratory, enormous in my book.
40 people is a big group, very big group.
Plus you're in the clinic,
you also have a life of
your own outside of work.
And to take the time to sit down with us
and share all this knowledge
that really is in service
to mental health and human feeling better
and in fact avoiding
often suicidal depression.
It's just incredible work
and incredible generosity.
And just thank you so much.
- Oh, thank you, man.
I mean, you know, similarly
I want to thank you
for what you're doing.
I mean, I think that what you, you know,
I've got a lot of friends,
folks that are not in
the medical profession,
friends of mine, you know,
one of my buddies who's
a real estate agent
who works with us, who's a
big, big fan of your show.
And you know, I told a
couple people like that
I was coming on and they
were like super stoked.
They're like, you know,
we watch every show
and, you know, super
excited to watch mine.
And they said something very
important to me that, you know,
you make this complicated neuroscience
and kind of brain-body
science accessible, you know,
in a way that few have a gift to do.
And I think that that's so important
and this show is doing so much
to help with science literacy.
And yeah, appreciate you, so...
- Well, thank you.
I'm gratified and
honored by your statement
and I look forward to more.
Thank you.
- Absolutely, thank you.
- Thank you for joining me today
for my discussion with Dr. Nolan Williams.
I hope you found our discussion
about psychedelics and other compounds,
about transcranial magnetic stimulation,
and about the treatments
for depression in general,
to be as stimulating as I did.
If you'd like to learn more
about the work being done
in Dr. Williams' laboratory,
you can go to the Brain
Stimulation Laboratory website,
which is bsl.stanford.edu.
And there you have the
opportunity to apply
to be in one of the clinical
trials for depression
or other studies,
as well, if you like, to
support the work being done
in Dr. Williams' laboratory
for the treatment of depression
and other psychiatric disorders.
If you're learning from
and or enjoying the Huberman Lab Podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please subscribe
to the Huberman Lab Podcast
on Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify and Apple,
you also have the opportunity
to leave us up to a five star review.
If you have questions for us
or comments about the
information we've covered
or suggestions about future guests,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
We do read all the comments.
Please also check out
the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning of today's episode.
That's the best way to support
the Huberman Lab Podcast.
Not so much today,
but in many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
we talk about supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them
for things like enhancing sleep and focus
and hormone optimization.
The Huberman Lab Podcast has partnered
with Momentous supplements.
If you'd like to see the supplements
that the Huberman Lab
Podcast has partnered
with Momentous on, you
can go to livemomentous,
spelled O-U-S, so
livemomentous.com/huberman.
And there you'll see a
number of the supplements
that we talk about
regularly on the podcast.
I should just mention that
that catalog of supplements is
constantly being updated.
As mentioned at the
beginning of today's episode,
the Huberman Lab Podcast has
now launched a premium channel.
That premium channel
will feature monthly AMAs
or ask me anythings where I
answer your questions in depth,
as well as other premium resources.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the premium channel,
you can simply go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
I should mention that the proceeds
from the premium channel go
to support the standard
Huberman Lab Podcast,
which will continue to be
released every Monday per usual,
as well as supporting
various research projects
done on humans to create
the sorts of tools
for mental health, physical
health, and performance
that you hear about on
the Huberman Lab Podcast.
Again, it's hubermanlab.com/premium
to subscribe.
It's $10 a month or $100 per year.
If you haven't already subscribed
to our zero cost newsletter,
we have what is called the
Neural Network Newsletter.
You can subscribe by
going to hubermanlab.com,
go to the menu, and click on newsletter.
Those newsletters include
summaries of podcast episodes,
lists of tools from the
Huberman Lab Podcast.
And if you'd like
to see previous
newsletters we've released,
you can also just go to hubermanlab.com,
click on newsletter in the menu,
and you'll see various downloadable PDFs.
If you want to sign up for the newsletter,
we just ask for your email.
We do not share your email with anybody.
And again, it's completely zero cost.
If you're not already
following me on social media,
it's Huberman Lab, on
Twitter, on Facebook,
and on Instagram.
And at all three of those places,
I cover topics and subject matter
that are sometimes overlapping
with the information covered
on the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but that's often distinct from information
on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
Again, it's Huberman Lab on
all social media channels.
And last but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[upbeat music]